[Music]
hey guys welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
today we'll be discussing the advanced
java full course
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies
so if you're a tech gig in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon so that you can never
miss an update
from simply learn so we'll start off
with understanding what exactly is
enumeration in java
then we'll continue with annotations in
java followed by that we have
serialization in java
then we'll dive into multithreading in
java next we have
synchronization in java and autoboxing
in java
later we will discuss about input and
output streams in java
advancing ahead we have few more topics
that are
java database connections that is jdbc
next we have generics in java
string handling in java and the
libraries which are java lang and
java util followed by that we will
discuss the networking
in java next we have images in java and
concurrency utilities for the next we
have a few more topics which are regular
expressions in java
non-blocking input output or n i
o in java next we have java beans
followed by that we will enter into
spring framework next we have the spring
model view controller followed by that
we have spring
and rest apis and finally we will
conclude this wonderful session
with a springboard project for a better
learning experience
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now we'll dive into the first
topic
over to our training experts hello guys
this is vikesh
and let's get started with enums or
enumerations
or enumerated types in java so
before we go into enums let's understand
why we need it
when you are building when you will be
building the java applications
you will face scenarios where you will
have to define
some variables which will remain
constant
forever for example months of the year
they are not going to change they are
always going to be 12 months
in an year similarly let's say name of
flowers
they're not going to change a lotus will
be a lotus
forever similarly the name of the
seasons will always remain same
the season of summer or winter will
always be called summer or winter they
will not be
changed the meaning of those variables
will never be overwritten or will never
be changed
so you can think of them as constants
but they are not
the constants which your programs may
mutate or your programs may
interpret differently they will be
interpreted by multiple applications
multiple components multiple consumers
in exactly
the same way similarly if you take the
example of time zones
they are fixed they work with the gmt
with respect to the gmt time zone and
they will always remain
like that so if you have if you whenever
you have a situation where you have to
define such constructs
or such constants always think of enum
types or
numerated types enum is basically a
language construct
and you can use this language construct
to define
type safe variables when we say type
safe variables
what we mean is that these variables
are not integer or string they are of
enum types
that's the reason java created a
completely new data type
which is called the enum type they are
by default constant
so you cannot change them that's their
property and the way you define enums
is like this you say public enum so
instead of the keyword class
you use the keyword enum and then you
define
the name of the enum the name of the
enum type
and then you define the possible values
just simply separating them
by a comma so for example days of the
week is again a constant thing
there will always be seven days of the
week irrespective of what you do
on this planet so that's why you can
declare an enum for the day
and you can define those as as the
values
you also notice that the values are caps
by default and yes that is how you
define the enums
let's have a look at a more interesting
example of the enums
in the ide now so if i switch to the ide
i have created a class called color not
a class but an enum
type called color and this enum type
color
is basically holding all the different
color types
their values basically like all the
vibger colors for example
so i've defined three colors here which
are red green and blue
so you see i've defined them as caps
they automatically become bold you don't
have to bold them
but you see an interesting thing a
difference here that there is another
value in the brackets here
this was not there when we looked at
this example of day there is no value
inside each of the enum types
but i have defined the value of the enum
types
and that is optional there will be use
cases where you want to define some enum
constants
where the name of the enum type is a
constant
which is a placeholder but it will have
an internal value
which may be more practical for your
application
so this is what your consumers see and
this is what
is used whenever you call red inside
your application
is just for simplicity there would be
there might be use cases where you use
some abbreviations and their full forms
for example if you want to use here an
abbreviation
of let's say wh o and inside this you
can define the value as
world health organization
so this is just a toy example i'm giving
you where you will
have use cases where you want to define
a constant
but you want to define an internal value
of it which is to be read by your
application elsewhere but everybody who
wants to consume
this enum can just use this particular
keyword and if they want to get the
value
they can get the value as well so this
is the use case where you might need to
define values
of your enum types as well but whenever
you have to do that
if you want to fetch the value of an
enum type you have to write some extra
code which is written here
if you were not defining the value of
your enum types
your enum can be as simple as this you
don't need to define anything else apart
from just defining the constant
of the enum types i'm giving a more
complex use case so that it covers both
of the things
of using just the constants and also
using the values
so if you just want to read the constant
you can just say color.red
or color.green or color.blue in
different classes and you will be able
to
refer to the enum types or use the enum
types but if you want to refer to the
value
of the enum type then probably you need
to call this method called
getvalue so whenever you define a value
what you would do
is you will define a private member
variable inside the enum which is
defined here
you can name it anything if you want you
define a constructor
where you set this particular value and
then you define a getter
so whenever some consumer application
wants to refer to the value of your enum
type
they can call this get value method to
get that
so this is the enum now let's see how we
can use this enum
for using this enum i have this main
class where i have a public static void
main method
and you can simply fetch the enum types
by writing the code like this just write
the enum type
holder and then type the enum type so
let me show you how this is done if you
just put a dot here you will get all the
enum type options
so i've defined three enum types red
green and blue and i get all the options
so whatever option i want to choose
i can just select here and i can store
this inside an
enum variable so if you want to just
refer to the name of the enum so this c1
is holding color dot red or red
so if you want to refer to this just
this red
then you can call the dot name method on
the
c1 variable so if you say c1 dot name
it is going to put or print the red in
caps and if you want to fetch the value
inside the red
remember the value is read in in small
caps
so if you want to refer to the or if you
want to fetch the value of the red
then you call the get value method which
we have defined here
so that's what we are doing here in this
first two sysouts where we are printing
the red
enum name and then printing the redinum
value
now you can also iterate over all the
enum types
and for that you need to call the dot
values method
on the enum so you can just say color
dot values
which is going to iterate over all the
enum types
and you are just storing each of the
enum type in this
color placeholder then you can either
call getvalue to get the actual value of
that enum type
or you can call the name to just print
the name of the enum as well
both of the options are available so
let's just put it back to get value and
let's run this code
so if i run this application i get some
output here which looks like this
first sis out says red enum name is red
in caps
because we are calling the name method
second says
red enum value which prints red in small
because we are calling the getvalue
method
and then we are iterating over all the
enums so i had three enum variables here
red
green and blue and i'm going to iterate
over all of them
one by one here printing their value and
not the enum constants
so that's why you see the red green and
blue here in small
but if you just want to print the enum
constants themselves
and not their values then you change
this to dot name
and then all the enum constants will be
printed here
so this is how you can create enums and
use enums for
the constants which are never going to
change in your application
let's get started with annotations in
java now annotations is a bit advanced
concept so let's understand why we need
it
there would be some cases in your pro in
your application
where you need to provide some metadata
information to the java compiler now
this sounds a bit complicated but it's
much simpler than that because you might
not want to
code everything with lot of lines of
code rather you want to give some smart
instructions
to the java compiler so that they
understand what to do
we have already seen some of the
annotations but the basic idea of
annotations
is to provide some shorthand metadata
information
about the program to the java compiler
generally annotations will not have any
direct effect on the
operation of the code they annotate but
they provide additional logic
to the code that's the idea with
annotation remember they are shorthand
metadata
the main use is providing information to
the compiler
or providing some compile time or
deployment time
processing or also providing some
instructions for runtime processing we
have already seen some of the
annotations
if you remember when we were dealing
with inheritance we had this add the
rate override
over the methods right this add the rate
override
is an annotation this annotation if you
if i if i show you what i'm talking
about
if i take you back to one of the
inheritance example
or the method overriding examples and if
i open the mountain bike class here
mountain bike extends bicycle you will
see this override annotation this is an
annotation
an annotation always starts with at the
rate in java
and the annotation name is overwrite now
this override is just a shorthand
to tell the compiler that hey i am
overriding this method from the base
class
that's what this annotation does if you
remove the annotation
in some cases the java compiler might
not understand what to do and the java
compiler has to do some extra processing
to figure out that this method is
actually being overridden
but if you put this at override here
then the java compiler pre-hand will
know
that this is coming from the base class
so you save some of the compiler
processing time as well
by using the annotation it's a shorthand
providing instructions to the compiler
you see exactly what i'm talking about
so this is one of the annotations which
we have used but we will look at some of
the other more generic annotations
and we will also see how we can build
our own custom annotation
in java you might have also seen some
other annotations like for example you
can put aggregate suppress warning
annotation which is a very popular
annotation
to suppress any kind of yellow warnings
in your code
generally we do not recommend doing that
but if you have a use case
then you can use at direct suppress
annotation as well
there are some other annotations as well
like admirate author if you want to
put your name as the author of a
particular piece of code then you can
add this metadata
so that whenever somebody looks at even
the documentation of your code
your name will be shown there as the
author so that's the idea with
annotations
so let's see how you can build your own
custom annotation whenever you have to
do that there are multiple ways to doing
that
and the first type of annotation we are
going to have a look at
is called marker annotation a marker
annotation
is just an empty annotation without
having any metadata logic at
all you can see it is i have defined an
annotation here i will talk about what
is
all this means but inside the block
there is no code here and this is how
you define a marker annotation
marker annotation is just to provide
very high level instructions to the
compiler
and the way you will write your custom
annotation is you will put
an access modifier keyword like public
then you will write
at the rate interface this is the
keyword which you have to use whenever
you are trying to create your custom
annotation
marker or no marker doesn't matter
whenever you define your annotation
you have to use ad grade interface once
you do that
then you provide a name for your
annotation which can be anything
but still not complete you need to also
provide more instructions to the
compiler or the runtime processor
to tell them when to execute this
annotation
and what the annotation type is going to
be applied upon
so at first you specify when this
annotation is going to be
active or executed or evaluated
so here you can say add the retention
which is
another annotation so you say add direct
retention and then you say retention
policy dot
whatever you want to write as you can
write it as runtime or you can write it
as source
if you write it as source then it is
going to be applied at compile time
and if you select it as runtime then the
annotation is going to be processed
at runtime so this is the first thing
which you need to provide the second
thing which you need to provide is where
this annotation is going to be applied
whether you want this annotation to be
applied to a class or to a method or to
a member variable
or to any other type and that's what you
define in the add the rate target
annotation you specify the target
audience for this particular annotation
and here inside the element type you
will get multiple options
you can apply this annotation to a
constructor to a field local variable
method
module package record component type etc
so here i'm going to use
type which means it can be applied to a
class
or a generic element type which
generally means class type
and that's all you can define your
marker annotation like this but
generally these marker annotations does
not have any logic so
you will not get much value out of it
until you have very special cases
but if you have a case where you want to
also run some business logic or provide
some metadata logic to the compiler
while defining the annotation
then you can define your annotation like
this so i've created one more annotation
here which called which is called my
custom annotation
again the target audience for this is
method
so this annotation can only and only be
applied
to methods if you try to apply this
annotation to a class
you will get an error the retention
policy is runtime it means it is going
to be processed at runtime and have
declared a method here which is called
int value so this is how you will
declare your annotation
now let's see how do you how do you use
this annotation so i have a class
called as my class here and if you look
at this structure of the my class
we create the class and then i create a
method which is named as
say hello and i am applying this
annotation on this particular method
remember the target audience of this
particular annotation was method so it
only be applied a method
if i try to put this on the class type
here
then i get an error here it says the
annotation my custom annotation is
disallowed at this location
because the type specified is of type
method
so the compiler will not allow you to
use this at an illegal place
so you write any method and you apply
your annotation but
you provide a value to the method the
int value method is going to consume
this value
and inside the method you can write any
other logic so let's see how this pans
out
i create a public static void method and
i create an object of my class
so my class h equal to new my class and
after that
i'm saying h dot get class dot get
method i'm basically calling
the method by using reflection api you
can also call the method
directly if you want but this is how you
need to call it if you want to use the
annotation property value if you want to
fetch the value of the annotation so
this is just an example of me showing
you how you fetch the annotation
so we created an object and then we say
get class which is going to return my
class type
and then get method is going to return
the method type
which has the name say hello so this is
a way to fetch
a method name or a method type from a
class
using java's reflection api which is an
advanced api you might you might not
need to use it but for the sake of demo
i'm using this
so we fetch the class and we fetch the
method it is going to search the class
for a method name say hello
if it finds the method it is going to
return the method in this variable
and then you can call method val which
was this variable
dot get annotation give me any
annotation which is applied on this
particular method
and you supply the annotation class type
as well once you do that
you get a my custom annotation reference
type
and then if you call the value method on
this you will get
this value as 10. so this is a way where
you can apply an annotation
and you can actually see the effect of
the annotation you might not always want
to do this because like i said
these are metadata instructions to the
compiler but
if you have a need to actually see what
your annotation is doing
you can use the getclass.get method to
first fetch the method
store it into a method type and then
call get annotation
supplying the exact annotation class
type and then
you can call the exact method which is
defined in your annotation
here i've defined it as value so i'm
just calling the value method so if i
run this particular example
i get the value as 10. so i'm able to
see or fetch the exact value which my
annotation metadata is holding at the
runtime
and this is the power of annotation
there are very powerful concept and
there a very advanced concept
they would be very rare scenarios in
your application where you need to
create your custom annotations
generally you will be better off will
with your with your predefined
annotations which are provided in java
like at the rate override
and variate author at the rate suppress
warning etc let's get started with
serialization in java
now before we go further let's
understand
why we need the concept of serialization
when you will be building the enterprise
grid applications
in in different organizations you will
often have a use case
or a need to send an object from
one application to other application
which is deployed on some other machine
so if you have a network of computers or
if you have a lot of different
uh complex setup where you need you have
a producer application and you have a
consumer application
producer application produces the object
and then this object
gets traveled over the network lines
over the network wires
and reaches at the consumer application
and
how does the consumer application
receive the object and how does the
producer application sense the object
because when the data travels over the
network lines it will be all bytes
so how do you convert a java object into
bytes
send it over network and then the
consumer application has to again
convert that bytes
back to an object representation and
then store that or use that inside its
application
so you need to do this whole conversion
right so the process of converting an
object to a byte so that it can be sent
over a network
is called serialization and the process
of converting back
the byte from the byte from the network
to a java object
is called deserialization so generally
you you may have a use case where you
serialize an object
create a binary representation of it
send it over the network
and that's where the java serialization
concept kicks in whenever whenever you
have to do this in java
you will be using the serializable
interface
so you need to extend your objects from
this
serializable interface so that those
objects themselves
becomes serializable you need to tell
java that this object
is able to serialize itself and
deserialize itself
and the way you will tell java is by
letting that object
implementing the serializable interface
let's have a look at an example
for of this serialization and
deserialization
to understand this concept better so
here again i've used the same student
class
where it has the name age and address so
you can see i have created a student
class
but the student class implements
serializable
this is something which you have to add
to your class second thing
the moment you do that all the modern
day ides like eclipse or intellij
will ask you to add a serial version
universal id to this particular class
this is
added so that java can uniquely identify
your
object once it is serialized and
deserialized
and it will also keep a versioning track
of it right because
when you serialize the object what
happens if somebody
hops over the network line and change
the representation of your object
and the consumer application will get a
completely different object copy now
so this is java's way to make sure
that the same version which the producer
application is producing
is received by the consumer application
so it's also sort of a security feature
it basically whenever you do an update
on to the object
it is going to increment this serial
version uid by one
so when you create the object first time
and you serialize it for for the very
first time the value is going to be set
as default 1
and as you mutate the object again and
again before deserializing it
the count will just keep on increasing
so that's how you keep a track of the
state of the
object which is being serialized by
adding this long serial version uid
you can also specify your own value if
you want to by default java initializes
a
value of 1 and this is a long type
variable so that is the only new thing
which is happening the moment you do
implement serializable
after that i have the same fields here i
have the constructor
and the setters and the getters and i
also have a tostring method just to
print the object nicely
where i print the name the age and the
address
so let's look at a main class and where
we use the student object we serialize
this object and then we deserialize this
object
so what is happening here is i create a
class
i create the main method and i create a
student object
this is something which we have already
seen then i want to
store the state of this object when when
you serialize this object
this object has to be either sent to a
network but since i'm running this demo
on the same machine
what i will do that i will serialize
this object onto my
local file system it's the same thing
right you can
put it somewhere and then fetch it from
there so either you can send it over the
network or you can put it on a file
system
so i create the object and then i need
to store this into a file
so far i have not covered the file
handling operations
so we will not go deeper into the file
handling classes here
but i will just explain you the
reasoning for it and when we'll do the
file handling session
there i will go in detail about the file
handling classes so i specify your file
name we are the serialized
representation of my student object
is going to be stored and this is the
location where i'm supposed to store
this
then i create two different classes
which is for
writing to the file and then creating an
object for it so that's what i'm doing
here
we can ignore this particular part where
i'm just supplying the file name and we
can focus on this part this line
where i'm saying write the object the
student object
to this particular file that's what i'm
doing here in this particular in this
three lines of code that i'm writing the
student object
to the file so when java has to write
this
object to the file it is automatically
going to serialize it
that's the only way java can write an
object to the file so
you serialize the object and then you
print that message that the object has
been serialized
again you can ignore this part as well
like i said we will not focus on this
but what we technically did is we just
wrote we just wrote the object to a file
by serializing it then i try to
deserialize it so i
load the file load this same file into
the java
jvm and then i read the object
and the way i read the object is by
using this object input stream class i
supply the file that
read this particular file and then i
call the read object method
which is going to return an object
a general object when you call the read
object method
the read object method does not know
that it is a student type
object so you so you need to explicitly
cast this to the student type so that
you can store this as a student object
if you do not cast this you will get an
error because
like i said read object does not know
anything about the student class so
what does what does this mean is that
when you serialize
an object the class type information is
lost
you cannot store the class type
information when you serialize an object
because the moment you call this write
object method
from the object output stream class so
you created this object output stream
class you supply the
file output location and you call the
right object the moment you call the
right object
it's just any java object for the this
java program
the signature of the student class is
lost it does not know that it's a
student class anymore once it has been
once it is being serialized similarly
when you deserialize it
the serialization api has no idea about
what student class is
and what student object is so you need
to tell the read object method
explicitly
that hey you are reading an object of
the student type and that's how
this line works once you explicitly
provide the casting operation
once you have casted it we try to print
the same deserialized object to see
if all the state which we stored in the
object
is still persisted there or not when we
deserialize it
so our major focus in this particular
class is this
object output stream classes
and the right object method these are
the two most important statements which
you need to take care of
the file output stream is basically a
file location what is an output
stream we will talk about that later but
whenever you need to serialize you need
to use this particular class called
object output stream
so that's all i'm doing here i'm
serializing the object
with this these values and then i will
deserialize and i will again print the
object to see
if these values are still there or not
so let's run this application
so when i run this application let's
start from here
first this says out gets called which
says object has been serialized so you
see
object has been serialized and what i
serialized was the student object
which had the value of name as john
age as 25 and the address as 23 east
california
and that's what gets printed here then
this whole block gets
completed this whole try block gets
completed it's a
standard try catch block you see i have
also added the i o exception
you need to do that because these file
operations will force you to
catch or throw the i o exception which
is a checked exception that's why it
will force you to do that
then we move to the deserialization
block where we create an
object of the object input stream class
and then we call the read object we cast
it to the student type and then we print
the object
so when i print this object this line
gets printed
object has been deserialized and then i
can see that the exact same state
is still there the name which is set in
the object is still there after being
after being deserialized
the age and the address is exactly
intact
so this is how we you can serialize an
object
send it anywhere you want and then the
consumer application need to read the
object and cast it back
to the student type and they will be
able to see the exact
same state which you saved in the object
just before serializing it what if you
have a use case where
you do you have a property in up in a
student class or in your object
but you do not want that to be
serialized that's also a use case where
you may have 50 different properties
inside the student class
and one of the properties something
which you do not want to serialize
because
you do not want the consumer application
to see that value
if you ever had that scenario use the
transient variable
so transient is again a keyword and the
moment you put this keyword in front of
a member variable
that variable becomes transient the use
case of transient variable is that if
you do not want this
x to be serialized and deserialized
then you put the transient keyword in
front of it the normal member variables
will automatically get serialized and
deserialized when the object is
serialized and deserialized
but if you have a use case where you do
not want a particular member variable
to be serialized or deserialized put
transient in front of it
and then have the getters and setters
for
this x variable and let's use this and
see if this actually gets serialized or
not
so i created the student object and let
me call student
dot set x and let's put a value to x
let's say 10 so i have set the value of
x
is 10 and x is a transient variable
and then i am serializing the whole
object here
and then i'm deserializing the object
and let's see if i'm able to
fetch the value of x after deserializing
the student object so i'm calling the
system.out.println
and the serialized
value of x is
object dot get x
let's see if i'm able to see the value
of x or not so
let's run this application again so this
is
exactly the same as before this is also
exactly the same as before but i see the
value of x is 0.
remember i set the value as 10 before
serializing it
but i don't see the value 10 anymore
when i deserialize the object
because it was transient if you remove
transient from it
then you will be able to transfer or
travel this value of 10
between serialization and d
serialization so if i just remove this
here don't change anything at all and i
just rerun the application
this time when i deserialize the object
the value of
x as 10 is still present there even
after deserialization
so this is how you can use the transient
variables
if you want to not have that object
serialized or deserialized when you're
doing the serialization
let's get started with concurrency and
threads the reason i want to talk about
concurrency because
once we understand about the concurrency
it will become much more simpler to talk
about threats
and the idea behind concurrency is very
simple and plain
and that idea is that as a developer
when you write a program
you would expect the machine or the
computer
to run multiple tasks in parallel for
example right now
i'm recording this video on on a
particular laptop which is regarding my
voice
which is also recording the screen which
is also running the eclipse ide
and also running a chrome browser it is
also have it also have opened multiple
background applications so there are a
lot of tasks running in parallel
at the same time and that's the idea
about concurrency
now how do we work with concurrency in
java is with the help of processes
and threads so these are the two basic
units of execution
when we talk about concurrent
programming in java and when we talk
about processes you can think of a
process
as basically an execution environment or
i should call it as a standalone
execution environment think of a logical
box which is completely cut out
from everything and it has its own
environment for example
again the recording software is running
it's in its own execution
environment and when we talk about
process process generally has
an everything or a private set of all
the runtime resources it needs
and the memory space it needs now this
another concept or another construct
which is very important is threads so
threads are also sometimes called
lightweight processes
and basically when we talk about threads
it's a thread also has an execution
environment
but creating a new thread requires lot
less resources
than creating a new process and you can
also think of
threads as a mini version of a process
because
a process can have multiple threads
remember that statement that a process
can have multiple threads threads always
exist
within a process and whenever you start
a process
there will be at least one thread
attached to it and each thread
is basically a task for example the
voice recording can be
a process and inside that the mic
recording
expression or the mic recording or task
can be run
by a particular thread let's take
another example that when you play games
let's say you are playing a racing game
so when you play the racing game
there are multiple things happening at
once you see the current speed
of your car or bike on the screen you
also see your leaderboard position
what ranking you have in the race
currently you also see some other kind
of
features like players health or the
car's health or the fuel
consumption available and lots of other
stuff the graphics
the motorcycle the other comp other
competitors
bikes and their speeds and their
distance to you as well
so if you see all of these are running
are different threads
there's a different thread to show your
current speed there's a different thread
to show the current leaderboard position
there's a different thread to show the
fuel
indicator etc everything is running in a
different
thread so all of these threads need to
run at the same time
in your program for a complete immersive
user experience
and that's what we mean when we say
multi-threading that we want multiple
threads to run at the same time to
create
a better experience in the application
so that's the basically the theoretical
part of it
please do read about more about how
threads work and how processes work
and there's a lot more documentation
available in the java docs as well
when we talk about threads but i will
keep the theoretical part to this
particular point
and now we will move to an eclipse
example
to see how we can create threads so with
that let's move to the eclipse ide
and here i have a demo prepared
basically
so what i have here is a threading demo
class which has a public static void
main method
and it has a simple for loop and inside
the for loop i see this strange code
here
where i am initializing two threads and
starting them
so that's all i'm doing here but let's
see how this thread one and thread two
class
have been written and why do i see two
different ways of initializing them
let's go deeper into this now so let's
see how thread one can be created
so first of all you can create a thread
by just creating a simple class
but make sure that you extend it with
the pre-built
thread class this thread class is from
coming from java
so from the jdk basically so the moment
you extend your normal class
from the thread class then you will have
to
override the run method so if i show you
the
thread class here this is the thread
class implementation available inside
the jdk and this is the class which is
getting
called when you are extending this from
the thread class
and this thread class will ask you to
override
a run method here the override
annotation is missing
so let me just add this for better
understanding
so you need to overwrite the run method
and this is something
which you need to do so that you can
specify what happens when you run the
thread
so this run method will be called
whenever the thread is
running at this particular point i would
also like to tell you that there are
different states in the thread so there
is a
thread which says thread is ready then
there is a state which is
which say thread is running there is
also a state where the thread is waiting
for
an i o input from the user from the
console or the command line
there can also be a state which says
dead where the thread has completed its
task
and it's not working there can also be a
state which is
called sleep state where the thread is
paused so there are different states of
the thread
and in this example we are going to
focus primarily on three states which is
the
ready state and the running state and
the completed state
so when you call the run method the
thread state is going to change to
running and whatever code you write
inside this particular run method
will be the logic which this particular
thread is supposed to execute
here i'm just putting a dummy logic
where i'm just
printing a cis out but definitely if you
try to create your threads
this will contain your actual business
logic for example that
fuel indicator code or for the
leaderboard position code will go inside
this run method
and then i'm catching an exception if
there's an exception but obviously there
will not be an exception coming in
because i have nothing here literally
so that's what we are we are doing when
we are creating this thread one class
and let's come back to the threading
demo now so to initialize a thread
or initialize might not be right word to
run a thread
the first thing which you need to do is
to initialize
the class containing the run method so i
would avoid calling this
class as thread because technically this
is just a class
so you initial so you basically create
an object of the thread
just like you create the object of any
other class there is nothing new here
right
so we just say new thread one and then
we call
t one dot start now if you observe
carefully
there is no start method here we just
had a run method
but this code is still compiling fine
and i'm calling the start method here
because the start method is the internal
method of the thread class
which in turn is going to call the run
method
so you are never going to invoke the run
method directly you just need to start
the thread
which is going to change the state of
the thread
from ready to running so this start
method has the responsibility of
changing the state to running
and the way the start method is going to
do that is by
calling the run method internally inside
the jdk
itself from developer perspective you
just need to call the start method and
that's it
the thread will start running and
whatever is present in the run method
will get executed so that's the way to
start the thread
second thing i have one more thread
created here which is the thread 2 class
so in this case when i create a thread 2
class
i am not extending it from the thread
class rather i am
implementing the runnable interface here
so this is a different interface
available which is a functional
interface which means
it will have just one method which is
the run method but the interesting thing
is that here when i created thread one
i said extend thread but here when i'm
creating the second thread
i'm not using extends thread but i'm
using implements runnable
let's understand why do we do that first
of all the reason
java provides two different ways of
creating threads
is because there might be a use case
that you need to
extend your thread to class from some of
your custom
java class remember java does not
support multiple inheritance
so at a time you can only extend this
class
from one class so what if there was no
runnable interface
and you need to extend this thread to
from student class let's say
so you need to do class thread to
extends
student for example the student is not
present here but let's assume it is
so you do this and then you also have to
extend it from thread
now java doesn't support multiple
inheritance and this will not work
so what would you do if you have to also
create it as a thread
but also extend it from some of your
parent class you will not be able to do
that
and that's the reason java provides the
implements runnable
because then you can extend it from any
of your super class of your interest
and at the same time also implant
implement it with runnable interface
so that you can treat this class as a
thread
so that's the reason java provides two
different ways of creating threads
remember that it's a very important
concept and once you implement runnable
again it will ask you to override the
run method so i will just put
overwrite annotation here so once you
override the run method again you can
write whatever logic you want this
particular thread to execute
inside the run block coming back to the
main class so
when you are extending from thread the
initialize
initialization is very simple where you
create the object
and you call the start method on the
object but if you are
creating a thread by implementing the
runnable interface the
initialization of the thread is a bit
different and it's different
in this particular part on the left hand
side you still say
thread t2 remember you are saying thread
and not thread 2. this is a
this is the java thread class this is
the jdk thread class not your own thread
class
so you say thread t2 then you say new
thread
and inside the new thread you provide
your
own class type thread 2 was your own
class type
so you specify your own custom thread
class here
inside the new thread constructor this
thread class
is the jdk class if you click on this
you will see
this is from the jdk class so that's the
difference
extending thread simple initialization
implementing runnable interface
do the initialization like this and
after that you call the
similarly the start method which is in
turn going to call the run method
so that was how you create threads
differently and now let's run this
program to understand
how the output looks like when we run
these threads in loops
remember i'm initializing 10 instances
of each of these threads
so in total there would be 20 output
lines so if i go to run as
java application i see this output here
so let's
observe this output for once so thread 1
thread 2
is running in sequence in the first time
but then you see thread 1
is running twice and then thread 2 is
running twice
then again you see a good sequence but
again thread two has run twice here
again thread one has run twice if i go
further down
thread one runs once then again thread
two runs twice
thread one runs once thread two runs
once so there is no particular order
here
though based on the code which we have
written we should expect
thread one is running from here and then
thread two is running output from here
in a sequential fashion but we don't see
the sequential fashion here
and this is the power of concurrency
this is because
threads never run in sequence they run
in parallel
and which thread will execute first you
can't really predict that
so it's so be very careful when you
whenever you're writing multi-threading
code because you cannot predict
the sequence of execution because
threads are going to run
whenever they find the idle cpu so the
key is the idle cpu
whenever a thread finds an idle cpu it
is going to occupy that cpu
and going to run its own execution and
the moment its execution finishes
the other thread will jump in and take
up and take a piece of the cpu so
whichever thread
gets the idle piece of the cpu is going
to execute
and that is the reason you see this
randomized output the next time you're
going to run
you will see a different random order so
so this time you see thread one ran
four times you you did not see this in
the previous execution
if you run it again you will see again a
different output this time the thread
one run price
so every time you will run this you will
see a different sequence there is no
guarantee of order
because the threads are running in
parallel and they are running whenever
they get the idle cpu that's the bottom
line
so this is how we are going to create
threads and
remember you cannot guarantee the
sequence of the execution
so write your code accordingly and use
the threads for independently running
parallel threads which do not depend
upon each other
let's get started with thread
synchronization in java
so in the previous example we saw that
when we execute
threads then we can't guarantee the
sequence
but it's actually technically not a
problem in the example which we
had look at before but it can become a
bigger problem
when two threads are trying to access
the same
object remember object has properties
and state
so what if the first thread modified the
object state
and the second thread is reading the
state of the object
the second thread is expecting the
original state but while it was
trying to read it the other thread
modified its state
so you can see this become a this can
become a big problem for example if you
are working with a banking system
and if there are two persons accessing
the same account
at the same time one is depositing the
money and
one is withdrawing the money from the
account and if the total balance is
thousand
and if both of them deposit 500 and
withdraw 500 at the same time then who
sees what
and if these are two if these are
handled by two different threads
then we can't guarantee if somebody sees
a 1500 as the total sum
or somebody sees a 500 as a total sum or
there can be a scenario where somebody
sees zero as the total
sum so it there so the application can
turn into really weird scenarios
if two threads are trying to change the
state of a particular
object at the same time and java
provides a solution of it
with the concept of intrinsic locks and
synchronizations
so the idea is that when a thread
tries to work on a particular object it
basically
takes a lock on that particular object
we also call this as an
intrinsic lock or monitor lock so it
takes a lock on the object
and it means that that particular object
becomes completely inaccessible to other
threads
in the system at that particular time so
the moment
you put synchronization or you put lock
on a particular object
only the thread which has taken the lock
will be able to access the object
and other threads will be forbidden from
accessing the object
so that's the idea behind intrinsic
locks and synchronization
so that was about the brief theory of it
now let's have a look at a practical
example
so i have prepared another example for
it so here i have again created two
threads
but these two threads it's the pretty
much the same threads which we covered
in the previous
session named as thread one and thread
two one is extending thread class and
other is implementing runnable
but that's the that's same but the
interesting part is this
both of them have a reference to a class
called mathutils if you see thread 1
also has the reference
and thread 2 also has the reference and
what the math utils is doing here
is basically you supply a number and it
prints the multiples of it
till 5. so for example if you supply 2
you will get the output
2 4 6 8 10. if you supply 3 you will get
the multiple of 3
up to 3 times 5 so 3 6 9 12
15. if you supply 4 you will get the
outputs
of the in the multiples of 4 till 20. so
whatever number you will supply
you will get the next five multiples of
that particular number
that's what this class is doing and
another thing
which interesting thing which i've done
here is this thread.sleep which means
that when you run this loop where you
are printing the multiples still five
of that number every time you do the
first multiplication then you
sleep for 400 millisecond and when i say
sleep it basically means the current
thread is going to pause its execution
for 400 millisecond and it is going to
leave the cpu
idle and if there is another thread
running currently in the system
that thread will get the share of the
cpu for that 400 millisecond
and once the 400 milliseconds is
finished the thread is going to wake up
and it is again going to hunt for the
idle cpu to pick up and start
doing its execution so that thread dot
sleep happens for 400 milliseconds at
every step of this iteration
in this for loop so thread one is going
to
use this particular method of this
particular class
and it is going to ask the class to
print the multiples of 2
and thread 2 is also going to access the
reference of the class and access the
get multiples method but this
thread asks to print the multiple of
three so thread one
asks for printing the multiples of two
up to two times five
and thread two wants to print the output
to multiples of three up to three times
five
so that's the basic scenario two threads
accessing the same object
supplying different values and expecting
the output so
if i run this demo as is without any
change here i'm just
initializing the math utils class
initializing two threads and then
calling the start only once
so if i run this particular program i
see get i see this strange output
that even when i said p1 dot start first
so t1 was holding
the multiple of 2 remember but i still
get 3 first then 2
then four six so multiples of two gets
executed
here but then the other thread takes the
cpu
and it starts running its own multiples
outputs and you see
nine printing first and then six gets
printed then twelve then 8
then 15 and then 10 at very last so the
output looks very random
it would have been nicer if i could have
seen 2 4 6 at 10 once
and then 3 6 9 12 15 once
if i see them in different sections in
different sequences that would have been
so nice because
then i know which thread is running when
and when
that particular thread is working on the
object so i'm just trying to replicate
the same scenario where two threads are
accessing the same object at the same
time
but they are executing the object
randomly they are changing the state of
the object
randomly here so how do we fix this to
fix this
we can put so we have this get multiples
method which is the
bone of contention here this is the
method which is being randomly accessed
so what i can do here that i can put
synchronized keyword in front of the
method so once you put the synchronized
keyword in front of the method which
is being accessed by multiple threads at
the same time
this method this whole method gets
synchronized now what this means
that one thread will be execute this
method
at once there will never be a scenario
where two threads are simultaneously
executing this get multiples method
or even getting a hold of this get
multiples method at the same time
there would be only one thread at a time
executing this method so if i put the
synchronized here
and if i rerun this example you see i
get a more streamlined output if you
notice
everything is one running like clockwork
where first the thread one gets executed
so i get two four six eight ten really
well printed
and then the second thread starts which
says three six nine twelve fifteen
the reason i get this output is because
when i did t one dot start it
immediately
went to execute the get multiples method
but it saw synchronized there
so it took a lock on the method and even
when the
t2.start might have got executed maybe
milliseconds after that or no seconds
after that
it still could not get hold of the get
multiples method
because thread1 occupied this particular
method it took a lock on this particular
method
due to the synchronized keyword so
that's the power of synchronized keyword
that you can take a lock on a particular
method
if you put it in front of the method now
there can be scenarios that you do not
want to
lock the whole method you still want two
different threads to
access the method but there can be very
few lines of code inside the method
which is the which is thread sensitive
code
now how do you spot that sensitive code
there is no magic
bullet there is no silver bullet for it
and it comes with experience
so you need to have that experience to
know which is the thread sensitive code
which can create problems if two threads
run that code at the same time
so the moment you have spotted that code
and if you don't want to
lock the whole method you can lock the
exact
lines of code by putting the
synchronized block
so if i remove this and i enable this
particular part
so what i am doing that i know that this
is the code which is
exactly causing the problem which is
creating this random output
so what i can do that i can put the
synchronized keyword
right before the block of the code
starts
which is thread sensitive and the way
you do that is you write synchronized
and you supply this which means whoever
has the current who
whoever has the object of the math
appeals that whole
object gets logged for this particular
block of code
so whoever has the math utils object
takes the lock on the object for this
particular block of code
if there were some other code which was
written in the get multiples method
before the synchronized block or
after the synchronized block that block
can be accessed by multiple threads
at the same time but this code will only
be accessible to one thread at a time
there will never be
there will never be a concurrent access
to the synchronized block that's the
power of synchronized block
and it will work the exact same way so
to show you if i run this particular
program i still get the output in the
same streamline way where first the
multiples of two get printed
and then the multiples of three get
printed so that's how you can
actually use synchronized methods or
synchronized block
to make sure that one thread is
accessing a sensitive object
at a time and there will never be a
scenario that two threads are
mutating the same object at the same
time again like i said
be very very cautious of when you use
synchronized blocks and when you use
threads
because threads have unpredictable
execution cycle execution sequence
basically
and synchronized blocks also have
problems if you have if you have
thousands and thousands of threads
running in your application
and if you put synchronized on a
particular method your application
may face severe performance issues
because all of the threads
will be executing that method in a
sequence imagine you put this onto a
huge application
or a huge ecommerce application or a
news website
it is it is going to create serious
performance issues so be very cautious
of how
and when you use synchronized method and
the key to that is to
have that developer dna to spot the code
which is causing this problem
which might be thread sensitive and
maybe you might need to change the code
itself
you might not need to go into the
multi-threading scenario and you might
you might be able to fix it without
using the threading or synchronized
concept
it completely depends but always have a
good trade-off when to use the
synchronized methods and synchronized
blocks
let's get started with auto boxing and
unboxing
in java so if you remember in the very
first sessions i talked about the
primitive data types
and then later on we talked about the
objects for example we had the
int data type but there later we also
saw an integer data type
which is which can also pretty much do
the exact same work which int data type
was doing
and we saw the similar kind of uh
experience
for the float data type and the float
class double data type and the double
class
care data type and the character class
and so on so forth so java provides an
easy way to convert a int
data type variable into an integer data
type variable
and also back from integer data type
variable
to an int primitive data type variable
now you might be wondering why we need
that
there would be scenarios for example if
you had an int
array as in primitive int array and if
you want to
store that into a collection now
collection can only be of
type of objects it cannot be a type of
primitive data type so you might need to
convert this int primitive data type
array into an integer object collection
so you need to do this conversion of
into data type to
integer data type and there would be
cases where you invited you might need
to do vice versa
so that's the basic idea about auto
boxing and unboxing
so when we talk about the definition you
can see auto boxing is the automatic
conversion
that the java compiler makes between the
primitive
and their corresponding object wrapper
classes
so whenever you are converting a
primitive data type to an object class
this is called auto boxing and when you
do the reverse it is called
auto unboxing or simply unboxing so
let's understand this with the help of
an example now
so i'm just going to open an example
about
auto boxing and unboxing so that we can
have a look at it
and here it is i've created a class
which is called auto boxing demo
it has a public static void main method
and
inside the method i'm first simply
declaring
an int data type variable i with the
value 10
then if i need to auto box this if i
need to convert this primitive value
into an integer object wrapper class or
an integer class type
then i need to write the code like this
which says integer
dot value of and then you can supply the
primitive data type value
and the output of it will be of type
integer
class so you get an integer object and
then you can print the object to check
if it is successfully doing the
autoboxing or not similarly doing the
other way round
once i have converted this into an
integer object
let's convert this back to a primitive
data type so
from integer object i'm converting this
back
into the primitive data type and you see
here
it's a simple assignment i just have to
assign the object to the primitive data
type
and that's it i can do the same for a
character
object and a cad data type so first i
create a character
object obj and then if i have to unbox
it
i can simply assign this cad obj to a
care
primitive data type ch and that would be
it
so you can do the similar drill for any
other
primitive to object wrapper conversion
let's say you want to convert a float
data type
to a float class or you want to convert
a double data type to a double class
then
whichever primitive data type has an
object wrapper class
you can do the auto boxing and auto
unboxing like this
remember whenever you have to do auto
box it means
you're going from primitive to object
and for that you need to call the value
of method
for example if you are converting a
double primitive to a double object
class
double object type basically then you
are going to call double dot value of
and similarly the same kind of behavior
will be seen
for other object wrapper classes as well
so for auto boxing you call the value of
and for auto unboxing
you literally just assign this to a
primitive and the object
wrapper class value will automatically
be assigned to the
primitive data type so let's run this
now and observe the
output so i had the int i equal to 10
then i wanted to convert this primitive
into the object wrapper
and the way i can do that is by calling
the value of method and supplying the
primitive data types value
so that's why i'm doing it that's what
i'm doing here and this i obj
should get the 10 value now which i can
see if i print the cis out and if i just
print the integer object
all together i get the value 10 so this
concludes that i've successfully
am able to auto box the primitive into
an integer object
now looking at auto unbox like i said
you simply can assign the
object wrapper to the primitive data
type variable and that should work
as is and that's why at line 15 we get
this output which says value of i1
is 10. similarly when we try to auto box
the character object so i have created a
character object here
and then i want to unbox this back into
a simple
care data type ch so when i print ch i
get the same value
and when i print the care obj i again
get the same value
remember the reason i've put this as
auto box is because
this by default is being stored into a
car data type i can also write it like
this for example
i can say care x equal to
a and then i can refer here as
character dot value of x
this will pretty much have the same
impact or the same effect
which i had just now it is going to
print the exact same output if i
rerun this program i'm going to get the
exact same output
so this this basically concludes our
understanding that you can use the auto
boxing and auto unboxing
pretty easily whenever you have a
scenario where you want to convert the
primitive data types
to the object wrapper classes or you
want to convert the object wrapper
classes
back to the primitive data types let's
get started with io
in java or io streams in java so when we
say io it basically means
input output and the basic idea is that
your program takes an input and gives
you
an output so whenever you have to do
some i o handling
generally the i o handling involves
taking input from
some external source it can be the
command line
it can be from a file it can be from
another consumer application
it can be from a hard disk but the basic
idea is that whenever you have to do
that input output handoff
or input output operation we call that
as io
generally whenever you will hear the
term io we refer to
the input output operations with respect
to the file system
or the hard disks or the external disks
basically
now when we talk about streams what is
an io stream
so the basic idea is that you have an
input source
you have an output destination now the
way the
input source sends the data to the
destination
is via streams so basically it converts
the data into one
and zero and that one and zero travels
as a stream
for example you can see this pretty good
image here where you have a data source
and you have a program and your program
is trying to read the data from this
data source which is basically sitting
on the file system and this data gets
converted into zeros and once
and then this is streamed to the program
bit by bit or piece by piece similarly
when
the program wants to send the data back
to the data source
it again goes in the form of stream
so when we talk about stream we also use
the terms
as input stream or output stream so a
program
uses an input stream to read data
from a source remember whenever we are
reading we will call it as input stream
and whenever we are writing something we
will call that as
output stream remember that because i
will be using this for these particular
terms
again and again in the demo so that's
the basic idea about streams
that you convert this into one and zero
and input stream means reading something
and output stream means writing
something so
now that we have built that
understanding let's have a look at what
kind of
classes support java provides to do this
io streaming operations so this is the
java io hierarchy where you have the
object super class
and then you have different types of
streams stream classes
so you have input stream you have output
stream you have reader
and you have writer so if you talk about
this particular section
in the input stream you have a file
input stream in the output stream you
have a file output stream this is
basically showing an inheritance
relationship
so you have the input streams for
reading something you have the output
stream for writing something
and you have java provides the classes
to
write to read from a file or to write to
a file using the file input stream and
the
file output stream class respectively
there are more classes under it but
only a few are few of them are shown for
simplicity
similarly if i go to the right side i
also have a reader class and a writer
class
which also have an input stream reader
and output stream reader
and again these have multiple other sub
classes like file reader buffer reader
and file writer
so i will also try to showcase the
understanding of why we need this and
why we need these
i mean ultimately you have to write a
stream right so by
creating two different types of classes
i will come back to that in a while
with that understanding let's go into
looking at an example
and let's build an understanding of how
do we work with streams
and this is also the session where i
will talk about the file handling
operations
in detail so to understand that
i have created two different examples
one for byte stream and one for
character stream so let's take that
concept first
why do you need two different types of
streams and the reason is pretty simple
whenever you are reading data from some
some data source or writing data to the
data source
so the data can either be simple
character strings
like english characters or the unicode
characters
or it can be some tabular data sitting
in a table in a database
it can be an xml file it can be an html
file it can be literally
anything it can be a mathematical
expression file it can be an image
you don't know that so that's the reason
java created two different types of
classes
that if you want to work on
a particular file which is holding
characters then you can use character
stream
and if you are dealing if you don't know
what kind of
data the file is going to contain then
just use byte streams
character streams also internally will
be using the byte stream only
but it is much more simpler and much
more faster to use character streams
if you just have character files also it
is worth noting
that when you are using character stream
the file will be
read character by character and when you
are using byte stream
the file will be read bite by byte so
one byte at a time and one character at
a time
so let's look at the byte stream example
first i've created a class called byte
stream example
it has a public static void bin method
and then i'm using the file input stream
and file output stream classes basically
what i'm trying to do in this example
is i'm trying to read a file and write
to a file
and like i said the uh when we look at
the theory
whenever we are using the input stream
term
we are primarily doing a read operation
and whenever
we are using the output stream term we
are writing something to the file
so for these kind of operations java
provides for file handling
java provides these two classes which
are called file input and file output
stream
so i create null references and then i
enter a try block and inside the try
block i basically provide a location
to read the file from so i've created a
source.txt in the java tutorials
location
and if i show you what this source file
is containing
so if i go to this location java
tutorials and if i open the source file
it just has a simple text which says
this is a sample text file let me delete
this
dest.txt for now so i just have a
source.txt here
which is containing a sample text this
is a sample text file
so i am reading the source.txt using the
file input stream
and storing the output into this in
stream which is a byte stream
and i'm also creating another output
stream where i will be writing the
destination file so i'm saying this
particular location
write the file with the name test.txt
but these are still just
containers i haven't done much here so
you are going to initialize the
reading stream and the writing stream
and then you are going to read one byte
at a time
till the time you reach the end of the
file the way to denote
the end of the file or the way java
tells you that you have reached the end
of the file
is when the read operation
returns -1 so you keep reading the file
till the read operation returns the
value as -1
whenever it returns the value as -1 it
means that you have reached the end of
the file
so i'm going to read this source.txt
byte by byte one byte at a time
till my re until i reach the end of the
file
so i call in stream dot read i store the
output of in stream dot read into a
variable called
content and at the same time i also run
this condition that
till the time this output is not equal
to -1
keep writing right where right to the
outstream
so i want to write to this particular
stream so i i call the write method
and remember this is a byte stream but
here i
the output of in stream dot read was an
integer output
so you need to convert this int output
to a byte by doing the explicit casting
here
so we do the explicit casting here so
that the int
con content gets converted into a byte
type and then
out streamed alt right writes that byte
inside the stream
onto this particular file so that's what
is happening here that you load the in
stream you read the file byte by byte
and you start writing the output file
byte by byte that's what you do in this
while loop once you have reached the end
of the file you will be broken out of
the while loop
because the whole file has been read and
whatever was written in that file
has been written to the outstream to
this particular file location
and then in the finally block you close
both of the streams
remember it's very important to close
these resources otherwise these
resources will be present
till the time java runs a garbage
collection so it's very important to
make sure that you close
all the resources which you open in
terms of file handling
these are costly connections and they
take up lot of memory so make sure that
you close them
in the finally block and that's why if
you see i don't have a catch block
here but i've put the finally blocked so
that i can say i can seamlessly
close them so that is what i'm doing
here and now if i run this
i don't get any output because i'm not
printing anything but if i go to this
particular location
and see if i have a dest.txt so yes our
desk.txt has just appeared which was not
there earlier
and if i double click on this it has the
exact
same text as i had in my
source.txt so the source.txt and the
desktop.txt have the same content
because
i've just written the source.txt to the
best.c.txt
so this is how you can use bytestream
operations
to do file handling now let's have a
look at
the character stream example it is doing
exactly the same thing
it's just that you have to use different
classes so instead of
file input stream and file output stream
we are going to use
file reader and file writer so i create
the file leader and filehead references
let's call it as reader for simplicity
and let's call this as writer so i
initialize file reader and file writer
again
pointing to the same location let me
delete the desktop txt
again so that we can observe the output
so
i create the object for file writer and
file reader
and i again do the same thing i call the
read operation
the read operation is going to return an
integer value output
and i i'm going to continue reading the
file character by character this time
the byte is not red but the actual
character of the file is being read
so i'm going to read this file character
by character
till i reach the end of the file which
is denoted by this condition
and as the output is int i need to
convert this into care
so i cast the int output to a care
output
and then write it to the writer then i
close the reader
and writer both and that's it so if i
run this now
and if i go back here i will see
desk.txt
and i see the output here exactly as
same
so in terms of output there was no
difference but since this was a purely
character file the character stream demo
is a better use case or like file reader
and file later classes are a better use
case
but like i said there would be cases
where you have to read it as bytes
because
for example if you're dealing with
databases or if you're dealing with
another type of files for example image
files etc
that will be traveling as bytes so using
a byte stream might be a better example
in that case and that's that holds true
for any other different type of data
source as well
let's get started with using jdbc in
java
to connect to the databases in this
example i'm using the
open source community edition postgresql
but you can use any database
vendor provider if you want to if you
want to use oracle or mysql
feel free to do that but in this demo
i'm going to use postgres
so you can download the postgres windows
installer since i'm using a windows
machine here
you can download the installer from the
official postgresql.org website
and you can also download the jdbc
driver for post resql
going to this particular official
website which is jdbc.postgresql.org
similarly you will be able to find the
jdbc driver for
all other database vendor providers as
well
once you download this this is going to
download a jar for you
and you can store the jar anywhere like
i put this jar into this particular
location
you can see this latest jdbc driver jar
for post sql so for every database
vendor there would be a different
jdbc jar which you need to download
so that's that you install the
postgresql you set up its database
and when you install the post sql you
also get a nice
sql client to talk to the database
because database has a server
and database has a client right so to
deal with that
you install the server and all these
database vendors like postgres oracle
microsoft sql etc they also provide a
nice
thin client with it postgres also
provides a client when you install the
postgres server it will also ask you or
it will actually automatically install
the sql client for it as well which is
called pg admin
so this is how the pg admin client looks
like the current edition of it is pg
admin 4
so you will get that installed
automatically and once your postgres
server
has been successfully installed if you
just go to search and type pg admin
you will get this option once you click
on this option a new browser window will
be opened
and you will see this client here you
will not see this particular window let
me let me close this one
but you will see something like this you
will see a server here
so you can go inside it you will see a
postgresql
edition here and if you go inside it you
will see a database here
if you open the database you will see
the postgres database by default created
so you can just right click on this and
create a database here
you can name it as whatever you want you
can leave everything
as is for now and hit save another thing
which you need to
do when you do the installation is it
will ask you to set a database user
and password so choose whatever database
username and password you are
comfortable with
and you will be using that user username
and password in your program as well
so create your database here and just
leave the database at this particular
point
and now we will try to connect to this
particular database
in the in the example which i prepared
i'm going to connect to this test
database
so let's go to the jdbc demo and see
what is happening there
so for this purpose i've created a class
called jdbc demo
it has a public static void main method
and there's a lot going on here
so let's take it step by step and i will
be keep shuffling between the database
sql client and this particular class
to build a nice narrative so if you
think carefully
what you need to have if you want to
connect to a database
the obvious answer is the address of the
database where
is the database you need to know the
location of the database
to connect to it so that is called the
connection
url every database vendor will provide
its own connection url and you can find
that connection url
from the official documentation there
are tons of examples available for it as
well but always refer to the official
documentation for that particular
database provider
the general syntax is jdbc
colon your database vendor's name colon
double slash the host name this can be
any ip address or your local host
generally we also put
a port here something like this 5432 is
the port on which the post resql server
runs
but again you can put the post the port
here on which your database server is
running
every database vendor has their own
default port the postgres sql server has
the default port as 5432 so you provide
the hostname you provide the port
and then you provide the database name
you provide the database name to connect
to so if you remember
i told you that i have written the
program to connect to this particular
database
called test so whatever that be you
provide that name here
and this is going to form the connection
url i can remove this for now
but this is how the connection string is
going to look like and it is going to
it's follow it follow the same format
for any database vendor that you say
jdbc column
you write the database vendor name and
then you say column double slash
you provide the host port and then you
provide the database name
so that is your connection url after
that
to connect to uh connect your java
program
to a database you need to use the
java.sql.connection class
this is very critical class and very
important and probably the single most
important class
which you need to have in your program
if you want to connect to a database
so you say connection con equal to null
i'm just getting a null reference to it
and before we go any further let me also
tell you why we need this jdbc and what
is actually this jdbc
so java is a programming language it
does not comes
with its own database but there are
multiple other vendors like postgresql
mysql
microsoft sql oracle etc so
java wanted to provide a uniform way
to connect to all of these databases
because imagine
all of these databases building their
own api contract
it would have been a nightmare for the
developers to
connect to different databases or shift
from one database to other database
and that's the reason java created this
nice interface
called jdbc and it said whoever wants to
connect to java
should follow this jdbc specification
and provide their implementation similar
to the
the interface and concrete class thing
it's not exactly that but you can
think of it in that manner that jdbc
provides an interface
with the method declarations and then
oracle postgresql mysql all these
database vendors are supposed to
implement that interface and provide
their own implementation
but jdbc apis will always remain the
same whoever wants to connect to java
has to create a driver and that driver
contains that implementation
and that's the reason we downloaded that
jdbc driver and i will come to how
how do we include that but that's the
background of jdbc and that's why you
need jdbc to build that uniform contract
and your vendor will provide their own
jar which will have the implementation
of the jdbc interface
and in this program what i'm trying to
do is basically
i'm trying to insert a record into a
table
so what is a table and how do you create
that so let's go back here
so in this test database you will see a
schema
by default you will see a public schema
and you can create a new schema if you
want to or you can just use the public
schema
so inside the public schema you will go
under and you will see a
an entry for tables so you just right
click and you say create
table you can also write in complete sql
statement but i'm just
showing you how to do that in pg admin
and you can give the table name
you can give the column information and
that's how you create the table
so i have created a table here which is
called student
and the student table has three columns
roll number
name and age if i show you the exact
query or the the whole create tdl for it
it looks like this so i created the
student
table in the public schema which has a
roll number
field or roll number column which is of
type numeric
it has a name column which is a varchar
or a character varying and it has a age
column which is again a numeric so roll
number name and age
these are the three different columns
which i created
inside the student table so i have a
student table with these three columns
so that's that now let's go back to the
program so i have the student table and
now i want to insert some records
in the student table so let me just
change the values here
so that we can see a different entry so
i have just hard coded some values
generally you will be getting these
values from somewhere in the program
but for simplicity let's say you have
got those values once you've got those
values the next thing you need to do
is to build the sql statement the exact
sql statement which the postgresql which
is going to be run on the postgresql
server
so you write that statement in this case
i'm showing you in
a creation example so it is going to be
an insert query so i say insert
into table name which is student and
then i provide all the column names
it is always a better practice to
provide the column names in these
brackets
even if you are inserting the values to
all the columns still provide the column
names
so i say insert into table column values
and then you provide the actual values
as the roll number variable
which i created here the name variable
and the age variable values
so i just supply the values here
remember the when you are inserting the
values
roll number and age are integer so you
don't need to put any single commas
single inverted commas for it but name
is a string variable so i put this
single inverted commas it's a simple
string concatenation nothing fancy here
so i'm just writing and a plain sql
statement here
and storing that into a string once i've
done that the
next piece which i need to do is to get
a connection to the database
and the way you are going to get a
connection is by this uniform method
no matter which database provider you
are using you are always going to use
the drivermanager.getconnection method
to get a connection
to the database and how do you get the
connection
you supply the connection url you supply
the username to connect to the database
and you supply the password in this case
i've just set the username and password
as postgres and postgres so postgres is
the username
and postgres is the password pretty lame
i accept but this is just for
demonstration purpose so it's fine
but generally you will be getting these
values from some application property
file
so these are the three parameters which
you need to supply to this get
connection method
and then you will get a live connection
to the database
this is this this is the line which is
going to make it all happen to connect
to your database server
so if this line gets executed
successfully you have a live connection
once you have a live connection the next
thing which you are going to do
is to create a statement object on the
connection
statement is it can be anything it can
be an insert statement or
a select statement or update statement
or a delete statement
everything is a statement there right so
that's why you need to create a
statement object
so you create a statement object and
then you execute the sql this
insert sql which you prepared you're
going to execute the sql here saying
st dot execute update execute update is
the method which is used for
any insertion or deletion operations so
that's the method you're going to use
and supplying the sql query
which you built with the actual values
of roll number name and
age the execute update method returns
the number of
rows affected once this statement got
run on the database server
or the sql query got run on the database
server
it might impact one rows if it's just if
it's an insertion
it might impact multiple rows if it was
an update query
right so it is going to return the
number of rows affected
and that is what we are going to use to
check if my insertion successfully went
or my insertion failed
so if this execute update is going to
return 1 which means that my row got
inserted successfully in the database
so i'm just printing us this out here
and if any
if this particular m returned zero which
means
none of the rows were affected by my sql
query which means my insertion operation
failed so i'm just printing assist out
here and then i'm just
putting this in a catch block here to
print any error and finally
closing the connection this is again
very very important
database correction is one of the
costliest connections
you will be creating when you will be
writing your java applications
always and always make sure to close
these database connections
otherwise your application is going to
face serious database bottlenecks
so we close the connection so that's all
we are doing here we prepare the url
we prepare we uh just create a
placeholder for connection object
we prepare our scale query with all the
relevant values
we get a connection to the database we
get a create statement we get a
statement object from the create
statement method
and then we execute the statement and
then we can validate the statement
execution
if there is a way to validate it once
you've done all of that
you close the connection so let's run
this program and see if we can see this
new record inside the student table and
before we do that let's also validate
what is present in the student table as
of now
so if i go here and i say view all rows
this is just going to run a select star
on the student table so currently
student table has one record with roll
number one
name as john and age as 20 and now i am
trying to insert another row
with roll number two name as jane and
age as
22 so if i right click and run as
java application i get this entry which
says
inserted successfully which is coming
from here insert it successfully and it
also prints the exact sql
so that you can see what sql actually
got executed
on the database server this is the same
string sql which i built
so this is the sql which got run on the
server which said insert into student
values and the roll number the roll
number was 2
and the name was jane with single
inverted commas because this was a
string
and then age was 22 this was the exact
sql which got executed so my sql has
been executed my connection has been
closed
if i go back to the pg admin client and
if i try to rerun this query
now i get two records so if you remember
this record was already there
but now i get the second entry which is
the new entry it just got inserted
because i did i ran the program and you
see the roll number two
the name as jane and the age as 22. so
this was a very simple example to show
you how you can do the jdbc correction
but one of the things which i still
haven't covered is the usage of the
jdbc driver the jar which i talked about
so
the way you are going to add the jar is
you go to the project
you right click on the project you go to
the build path
go to the configure build path and there
you will see different tabs
source projects libraries so go to the
libraries tab
and select the class path here and you
can choose the add
external jars option click on this
load your sql jdbc jar for your
particular database vendor for my case
it was post resql let me just quickly
remove this jar and show you
right from how it's done so this is how
it will look like for you
you select the class path you click on
add external jars
you go to the location where you have
downloaded your jdbc
driver jar for your particular database
select that
click open it will come here hit apply
and close
that's how the jar is going to be there
if you don't provide the jar your
program is going to fail miserably
it is not going to work so make sure
that you have the jar and then
only it is going to be able to create a
successful connection and be
able to successfully execute the query
remember jdbc
provides the specifications and then the
particular database vendor
like postgresql provides the jdbc driver
which has the implementation for that
jdbc api
and that the java has this uniform jdbc
avi
api and every database vendor is
expected to honor
and implement that api only so that java
developers can
work on the jdbc contract and everything
should work as is
let's get started with generics in java
so before we go about generics let's
understand why do we need generics
and what what was the requirement that
led to the creation of generics
so as we know that when we work in an
any object-oriented programming language
we created classes we create objects we
create variables
and everything has a type everything has
a type and that type is static
the type cannot be changed that's why we
call java as
a strong type checking language at
compile time
it checks the types of the variables of
the classes at the compile time and if
the classes are mismatching or their
types are mismatching
then you basically get a compilation
error but
what we see as we as we moved along we
saw that
we were creating the similar kind of
functionality again and again in
different classes
for example if there is a login
functionality which should allow
a person to log in and we should also
allow an application to log in
then these are the two different use
cases but the functionality still
remains the same
so how would the login functionality
allow both of the types
of entities be it user or application to
get into the application
or login into the consumer application
how do you do that
and that's what led to the creation of
generics that you can reuse
the same code with different types of
inputs
remember the stress here is on the types
and that's what it is mentioned here
that we will like to reuse the same code
with different inputs
we will just keep changing the type
parameters and we'll keep using the same
same code again and again it has some
benefits over the non-generic code like
we mentioned like i mentioned earlier
that when we work with the
non-generic code we have the statically
assigned types
to the variables and objects and if we
use generics then we don't have to do
that
and at the same time you don't even have
to explicitly cast them
we touched upon this concept of generics
in different bits and pieces in
different sessions throughout this
tutorial series
where we saw that whenever i was
creating a list i was supplying
this type into these brackets right and
i told that this that this is the
generic type
but now we'll go deeper into this
concept and we'll see how we can create
our own generic types
if java does not provide it so with that
let's move to an example and see how we
can
implement our own generic types to
create generic
code where we can supply the types
dynamically
so i've prepared an example for this
i've actually prepared two examples for
this and we'll go through
both of them one by one so here what i'm
doing that i'm creating any class you
can think of it as any class holding any
functionality
which is applicable to multiple entity
types
think of it as the same login class
which i just talked about so
if your class has a functionality which
should be
reused by many different types
then one of the way to not repeat the
code or repeat the class or repeat the
functionality again and again
is to make that class use a generic
signature
and how you do that you write the class
name and then you put
these brackets and you just type t you
can write any variable abc or whatever
you feel like but t is sort of the
default standard
the java developers have been using
since generics was launched
so you put this t here now whoever
calls this class or whoever whoever
initializes this class
will have to supply the type of the
class on which
this particular functionality is going
to get executed
now remember the collection examples i
took i took
in the past series what if this was a
list class because we have used the
exact same syntax right we use list
we put brackets and then we wrote string
and we said okay now this
list is a list of strings if we said
list of integer then we just
write integer in these brackets and that
list became a list of integers
so you see the same list was being
reused for different data types
and the exact same concept is applied
here for your custom classes and your
on your own custom functionality so i
write t here
then i can do whatever with this t i
want so i just
uh put a reference of it inside the
class i
create a constructor constructor is also
assigning
the t type i do a get object and that's
all it's a very simple
toy example but just to get the point
across you can write as complex logic
as you want inside the class depending
upon your use case
but this is just a straightforward
example that you can use generics in the
classes as well
once you do that then how do you
initialize this class so let's have a
look at that as well
so i've just created a public static
void bin method inside the same class
obviously you can create this method
outside the outside this class as well
there's no stopping
that logic but but for the sake of
simplicity i've just put the main class
here
so it's a simple public static void main
method there i
am initializing the single generic
holder class the same class
and here the t type is of integer this t
type can be of anything else as well for
example your own student class can also
be
supplied here and then the single
generic holder will become of student
type
in this case i'm just using a pre-built
java class
so this single generic holder becomes of
integer type
i give a reference i create an object
and i provide a value to the object
because you see the constructor is this
whatever t you supply so if the t is the
integer
this t becomes integer and this obj is
going to hold the value
10 because that's the constructor being
called here and after that you can
do whatever you want in terms of the
logic here i'm just i just have
i just have a get object method so i'm
just calling that
method and printing the object that's
all similarly you can
also initialize the same class with the
string type
so you see i'm reusing the same class in
the same functionality
again and again for different class
types so this time i'm using the string
type
instead of integer and i'm supplying a
string parameter this time and this this
constructor still will work
because this is generic when you created
with integer
this constructor this t became of
integer type
and when you initialized it with the
string type this
constructor started accepting the string
objects
so just supply a string called simply
code and then i call get object
so let's run this method so when we run
the main method
from the first invocation at line 16 and
17
when you call the get object the value
of the object
gets printed which is 10 for the integer
and then at line 20
the value of the string gets printed
which is simply code
so that's how you can use generics
inside
a class or for a class now there might
be use cases
where you have to create a class which
can accept multiple types of generic
types
let's take an example if you remember
when we talked about hashmap
we had the exact same situation so you
had the key
and you had the value now key can be of
any type any data type it can be string
integer whatever
and then value can also be of any data
type
it can also be your custom data types
for example the key becomes a roll
numbers
and the value becomes student object
so map is a situation where you have two
generic types
so i'm just trying to replicate that
similar kind of behavior that if you
have to create a class
with two three as many generic types as
you want you can still do that by just
providing a comma here
you can go on doing as many generics as
you want in this example i'm using
two generics and then it again goes to
the same drill that i created references
for both
d and u i have initialized both t
and u in the constructor and then i have
a display method which is going to
call the and display the obj1 and obj2's
values
or their two string methods basically
because when you when you try to call
the object inside the system.out.println
method
the by default the tostring method of
the object will automatically get called
so that's all i have in this particular
class so i
it's a simple class accepting two
different types of generics
and then calling the display method and
here is the public static void main
method for the same
here i am initializing the dual generic
class
and here the t is string and u is
integer so these t and u are
assigned these class types and then i
create the class i again write the same
types and i provide the value
so for the string one i provide simply
code for the integer one i provide 10
this constructor gets called obj1 gets
the value simply code
and obj2 gets the value 10 and then i
call display method
there i am printing obj1 and obj2 so
let's run this method okay i'm getting
simply code in 10
because when i call the display method
at line 13 obj 1 gets printed
obj one is holding simply code value and
at line 14
obj2 gets printed or the two string
method of the obj 2 gets printed
which is holding the value 10. so this
was a quick tour
to tell you how can you use generics you
can obviously use generics in the
variable types as well
you can use generics in the method
argument types as well wherever you want
the simple idea is that one you would
like to reuse
the functionality again and again and
second
you would like to you would not like to
have a strong strict
type checking and like i said try to
relate
these generic concepts with the
collection framework we listen because
collection framework is completely built
upon the concept of generics whenever we
initialize a list or a map or a hash set
or a linked list
or error list or anything we always
supply the type and that type is coming
from
these if you look at the implementation
of error list class
you will see that let me see if i can
open that for you
to show you how that looks like if i go
to an example
of collections and if i try to just
open the class you will be able to see
that yep
so if i click on this list class you see
list of e
type so here e is the type which you are
going to supply
so in this particular case when you say
list of integer
this integer gets typed into e
so whatever so this this whole list
class whatever operations you are doing
inside the list class
will be applied for the integer type so
similarly you can look at other
collection classes and you will always
see these generics everywhere in the
collection classes
let's get started with string handling
in java so we have been dealing with
string types
throughout different sessions in this
whole series but in this session we are
going to look at
lot of different utility methods which
the string class provides
string class is very versatile in java
and it provides lot of handy functions
which can help you manipulate strings in
multiple ways
for example if you want to trim a string
or if you want to append
a string to another string or if you
want to find a particular character at a
particular index
or if you have an index and you want to
see what character is present at that
particular index
or if you want to do any other kind of
pattern matching in the string
so string is very versatile in that in
that context and today we will have a
look at some of those methods
so i've just opened the java docs api
for string and you can see in the method
summary you will find a long list of
methods
we will go through some of these methods
for example if i just
show you a snapshot of what i'm talking
about it has a careat method
so you provide a index and integer index
and
this particular method will tell you
which character
is present at that particular index in
the string
remember string is basically a zero
based character
array zero index based character array
similarly you can also call code point
at which is going to return the
character
in the unicode code point at a specified
index
similarly compared to method can be used
to compare two strings with each other
compared to ignore cases also there
which can compare two strings
ignoring whether they are in uppercase
or lowercase you can use concat method
to
join two strings together you can use
the contains method to find if a
particular character or a particular
sequence of character
exists in a particular string or not
you can do a content matching you can do
copy
you can also see if a particular string
ends with a particular character or a
sequence of characters
so there are tons of different methods
available here
and please do check out the api because
like i said this is going to come very
handy when you start
writing real time projects or the real
life projects
so with that knowledge let's go to uh
our ide
and let's have a look at some of these
examples in action
so here also you can obviously have a
look at the string class uh
uh from the ide itself just write string
and
hit control and you will see an
underline and hyperlink
so just click on this and you in the
string class will be opened and you can
actually read on about the documentation
of the whole string class but we are not
going to do that we are going to have a
look at some
real life examples of how we can use
different methods of the string class
so here i've created two strings str1
and str2 str1 is holding a string which
says john is studying
and str2 is holding a string which says
in college
now the first utility function which i'm
going to talk about is the length method
so if you want to find out what is the
length of this particular string
then you can just call the length method
on the string and that is going to
return
the length of the current string let's
see that in action let me comment the
rest of the code
and let's see this one in action so if i
run this program
i get the value 16. so if you count this
1
2 3 4 space is also counted
5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15
16. so you get the exact length of the
string when you call the
length method similarly another method
is
concat method and concat method is used
to concatenate two strings together
concatenation basically means joining
two strings together
so if you want to join the string one
and string two
then just call str1 dot concat
with the string you want to append or
you want to concat
so the concat method on the left heights
left hand side of the string is going to
get concatenated
with the argument which you pass in the
concat method
so let's see that in action now and
let's see the result as well
because i'm storing the result of
concatenation into a new variable
and printing that variable so i get this
whole text here and you see
the studying in just got merged there
was no space in between because
there is no space here if you just put
it like this
and if you rerun this you will see the
proper space as well
while concatenation one of the things
which i also want to call out is strings
are immutable in nature when i say
immutable it means that once you have
created this str1
holding this value then st and then this
particular object's value pointing to
str1 cannot be changed
you cannot mutate the strings if you try
changing str's value
java is going to create a new object and
point str1 to that object
but the object which was created
initially is not going to be overwritten
so remember that concept that whenever
you are doing manipulations on the
string
the previous string object still remains
there it doesn't get overwritten or it
doesn't get modified
whenever you modify a string you get a
new object that's the property of string
so we saw the concatenation let's move
ahead uh this also
format method format method is used to
dynamically populate some parts of the
string
for example if you have a long list of
students and if you want to print the
name of students
then what you can do here is that you
can change
you can assign those names to certain
variables
and you can point or refer those
variables in the string
with the percentage syntax percentage s
syntax basically so the string.format
method
is used to supply dynamic values inside
a static string
so in this case this part of the string
is static where i'm saying the name of
the student
is then in the next string remember plus
also can concatenate it it is also doing
the exact same thing as the concat
method
you can it's just a shorthand so i'm
creating first string
then i'm creating second string but here
i'm writing percentage
s i will come to that and then i've
created one more string
where i'm using percentage b so what
happens
that java format method supports certain
special type
of references for example if you want to
dynamically
place a string you can use percentage s
if you want to dynamically
place an integer value you can write
percentage d
in the format method similarly you can
also write other percentage f
for for a float value and there are more
other similar
placeholders which are available in the
format method so do check out the format
method documentation
if you want to know what all percentage
types or variable types can be
dynamically placed inside the format
method here i'm just using percentage s
and percentage d
and then once you have created the first
part
of the format method which is string
with with dynamic placeholders
till this particular point then you put
a comma and you start providing the
values
remember the sequence of the values have
to be exactly the same way in which you
have used them here so if percentage s
is coming first
then you have to supply a string value
if percentage d
is coming after that after the string
value you have to provide an
integer value if there was another
percentage s after percentage d
in the same string then after 21 you had
to provide another string value
so that's the contract which format
method
needs to honor and if i run this
particular program
and if i say if i try to see the output
let's try to see the output as well and
for the output i need to store
this uh whole string dot formats output
into a variable so let's say i say
string
r and then i can print r
and see what comes out so that's it
let's run the program now
and now you will see this line the name
of the student is
john comma and the age is variable is
21. i think it's coming because i've
just wrote variable is here
but if you if you remove this and if you
say the age
is percentage d then you'll get a
nice human readable output without any
extra formatting so the name of the
student is john and the age is 21
and that there was a comma that's why
you still see the comma but this is the
basic idea with using the format method
now another method which i want to talk
about is a cad at method
let me comment the previous output so
that we can follow along
so i'm just going to comment all of this
which we have covered already
and let's focus on the care at method so
caret method
can be used to find the character
present at a particular index in a
string
so whatever index you specify in the
caret method
the character present at that particular
index
will be returned so when i say str1 dot
care at 5
remember strings are 0 based indexed
character
arrays so 0 1 2
3 4 5 at 5 i is present
so this car at method should return i so
if i run this
particular program yes i see the output
as i
now let's move ahead uh with next
example
or the next api call the next api call
is the usage of equals method where i
can see if the two strings are equal
or not so here i'm saying str1 dot
equals str2
if both strings are same it is going to
return true otherwise it is going to
return
false so if i run this i get the output
as
both strings are different it goes in
the else block because
str1 and str2 are different they are
holding different values so here the
exact content of the string
is going to be matched the next one is
the index of
method so index of method can be used
just for the reverse functionality of
care add in carrot we were supplying the
index and getting the character
here we can supply the character and get
the index of it
so what what is going to happen that you
write the
string dot index off and then you supply
the character
which for which you want to find the
index of so i supply y here
and if i run this particular program for
this line
the output is 12. let's see if the
output is correct
so here if you try to find what is
sitting at the index number 12 in this
string so again 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12. so yes y
is present at the 12th index and that's
the output i get
what if you provide a character which is
not present in this particular string
that says z which is not there and see
what the output is
in that case you will get the output as
-1 so if the character is not present in
the string
you will get the output as minus 1
another thing what if the
character is present more than once in
the string for example i
is present more than one time in the
string so if i write i here
whether i get the index of this i or
this i
let's see so i'm going to run this
program again and i get the value
5 so 5 is basically this i because this
is definitely not
5 it's far far further index so the
first
match of the index is going to be
returned
in terms of the index of method okay so
that was about the index of
let's look at the next one which is the
replace in replace it's
as the name suggests you can replace a
character or a sequence of characters in
a string
by calling the replace method on the
string on which you want to do the
manipulation and remember you are doing
the manipulation here
so the previous object is not going to
get overwritten but
a new object is going to get created so
what i want to replace
is with r so in this particular string
i see an occurrence of s here so this s
should be replaced with r if the replace
functionality works as i just explained
so let's run this program and yes i can
say instead of
s i see r being replaced there and
that's the usage
of the replace method next one is the
split method where
if you want to split the string into
multiple
elements so you just call the split
method and you provide the separator
here i am separating the string whenever
there is a space
i'm basically breaking up the string
into multiple sub strings that's what
i'm doing here
or multiple strings i would just call it
as so whatever
separator you provide whenever the
string is going to encounter that
separator it is going to split one part
of it
so in on providing the separator space
it means
in this particular case i'm going to get
three items the first
breakup is going to go going to happen
here so the john part of it will
go out and this will go out in a
separate string then again
between is and studying i have another
space so there will be another break
here so i should get three elements
if i call the split method one element
will be holding the value john the
second element will be holding the value
is and the third element will be holding
the value as studying
and then i'm printing all the elements
of the of the
array remember that split method returns
a string
array so that's what i'm using here to
store the
output of the split method and then i'm
just using the streams api
to iterate over this string array
outputting or printing the each element
of the array
so let's run this program okay so i can
see three different outputs
through this system.out.println first
john
then is then starting like i said split
method is going to
create a three element size array of
strings
because i'm separating it based on the
space the last
utility function which i want to talk
about so this is the last one but i'm
skipping some of
some more due to the interest of the
time but like i said do check out the
documentation
to read or understand more about other
string utility methods
which i am not covering here in this
session so the last one i'm going to
talk about is the substring method
and substring is basically going to take
a mini string out of the long string
so what if you want to trim the string
what if you have a long string and you
only want to get a part of the string so
you can specify the
starting point we can specifying the you
can specify the end point
and whatever string characters are
present between the starting index and
the end index
will be taken out from the string and
you can store that output into a new
string
and print that so here i'm calling the
substring method providing the starting
index as 1
and the ending index is 5. let's run
this program and interpret the output so
i'm getting the output as
o h n so what is happening here let's go
back to the
str1 so i said start with one
remember string is a zero based index so
it starts with zero
one it starts with o because o is
present at the first index
and then i'm going up till five so one
gets printed
whatever character is present at one
index get printed second index get
printed
third index gets printed fourth index
gets printed which is just a space
and then the fifth index is i which is
not printed here so it means that when
you call the string substring method
then the end index position will
not be printed it starts from the
beginning index
and it will go till index mine end index
minus 1 position
in terms of printing because if you
select this you'll see an extra bar here
because the space is also getting
printed so it is printing everything
before the fifth index
it will not include the fifth index
character remember that when you use the
substring functionality that the end
index is not included in the substring
if you want to include that
you need to increase the index by one so
for example if you want to
print i as well then you have to write
it as
index s6 and if you run this then you
will also see i now yep
so that is how this substring
functionality works
let's get started with java.lang package
so
java.lang package is one of the most
core and fundamental packages in java
which is provided out of the box to the
developer you never
explicitly import this package in your
java program
because you don't need to java provides
this automatically the moment you
create a file with java extension or and
you have
you are running that particular program
inside or on a jdk
you get the java.lang package
automatically for example
when we were when we were running the
string handling demo i was using the
string class
but i never imported the string class
you can see there is no
import for string because string class
is also part of the java.lang package
it's automatically imported for you you
never need to explicitly import the
package
or any classes of that package so this
is going to be more of a theoretical
lecture where we will just have a look
at or a quick
overview of all the java.lang package
classes
and other utilities you don't need to
remember all the classes and utilities
but this is just to give you a sense of
what all it contains
so in terms of the interfaces it has the
appendable interface
autoclave auto closable care sequence
clonable
comparable if you remember we also used
comparable when we were
writing the comparable implementation to
compare different objects in a
collection so this also comes
automatically as part of the java.lang
package
iterable runnable again we use this in
the in the threading example
so this also comes automatically to you
you never need to
import the enable class from the
java.lang package
when we move to the classes all the data
type classes which you can think of
in terms of boolean byte character class
class loader compiler
enums even float integer long math
so all the classes which we were using
the the data type classes which we were
using in different examples are also
part of the java.lang package
okay so this is a long list long list it
also has a thread class so whenever you
are creating thread you again
never imported thread class but it still
just worked fine
because there was this was also coming
as part of the java.lang package
there are also bunch of enumerations
which it provides in terms of unicode
thread state etc it also provides
exception classes
like arithmetic exception or or that the
different runtime exceptions which we
dealt with
like array index out of bound array
store class cast
class not supported the root exception
class
so a lot of exception classes also come
as part of the java.lang package
it also provides some error classes if
you remember when we talked about the
exception framework you have the
error types and you have the exception
types so it also provides some error
classes
if you want to use that you don't you
never need to import any of these
classes
and you will automatically get them from
the java.lang package
similarly it also provides some
annotations as well
like functional interfaces or you
remember we use this annotation a lot
the add the rate override annotation
but we never imported the override class
or the override annotation
because it's part of the java.lang
package so
this basically tells us that there are a
lot of different classes
utilities enums errors exceptions data
types
which are provided out of the box from
the java.lang package
which makes our life so much easier
whenever we want to work with java
because we don't need to import the very
basic classes which
which we use very frequently and another
very
important package is the java.util
package
we have been using the java.util package
in all of the collections
examples and tutorials we walked through
in this whole tutorial series
so let me just open the java.util
package for you
so if i go here to java.util
and i will be able to see the java.util
packages different classes etc yes
so here is here it is the java.util
package
and remember java.util package is not
imported
automatically you have to explicitly
import the java.util package to use the
classes of it
so it so that's the difference between
java.lang package and java.util package
that you cannot
you can use the classes coming from the
java.lang package
without explicitly importing those
classes or importing the java.lang
package
but java.util package is something which
you have to explicitly
import in your java program to make it
work or even make it compile
so what java.util provides first of all
the collections framework
the whole collections framework comes
from the java.util package
so for example all the interfaces which
we use while we work with the
collections framework classes
interfaces like collection list set
map you can see the map interface you
can see the list interface with the
generics
so all the interfaces which we use from
in the collections framework are present
in the java.util package
similarly when we talk about the classes
all the concrete classes implementation
of the collections framework
in terms of error list linked list hash
map hash set
preset tree map you will see all of
those classes here
here we are covering all the this is
showing all the classes summaries so you
see some abstract classes
and you will also see some concrete
classes as you move further down
in this particular list so you see hash
map you see hash set
hash table linked hash map linked asset
linked list we used all of these classes
while we were going through the
collections framework tutorials
so it provides all of these and lot of
other classes like the scanner class
which we covered in the java project for
taking the inputs
from the command line from the user
stack class again from the collection
some time classes and it also provides
bunch of enumerations
like the local basically setting the
language categories
for a particular program it also
provides some exceptions which we used
while we were working with the
collections framework so
most of these exceptions are or some of
these exceptions are related to the
collection classes for example the
concurrent modification exception
gets thrown uh whenever you your the
whole
execution detects concurrent
modification of an object
when such modification is not allowed
you will see other different types of
exceptions like illegal format etc in
this particular
exception section of this particular
package
then it also provides just one error
class as well
so this is what the java.util package
contains and
just to refresh your memory whenever we
ran any collection demo
we always imported the java.util classes
you can see this is all coming from
java.util so this is something which you
have to import without which your
program will not even compile
so that's also one of the difference
between the java.lang package
and the java.util package and that's
pretty much all i want to cover in this
particular session
so we basically did a quick tour of the
java.lang package and the java.util
package
and like i said it's impossible to cover
all of that for all of the classes
and enums and interfaces and errors and
exceptions
with all the examples so i would suggest
you to just keep this in mind about the
java.lang package and java.util package
i told you the basic concept that
java.lang contains all the types
the class and the variable types or the
data types we dealt with
and java.util majorly contains all the
collection classes
that's that's that's the basic uh thing
which you need to remember whenever you
work with java
and your java.lang package never needs
to be imported but java.util package
needs to be imported always whenever you
use the util classes
let's get started with networking in
java so when we talk about the
networking in java
java has a whole dedicated package
called java.net package
which has all the different classes
which you need to have
to write a networking program in java so
we'll
you will see bunch of classes with two
classes most important ones
which are i net 4 address and inet 6
address so
as you can see you can understand that
inet 4 address
is the class which can be used to
represent the ipv4 addresses
and inet 6 address class can be used to
represent
ipv6 addresses and then you can learn
about sockets
it also has socket classes it has a lot
of interfaces the with the prominent one
being the networking interface
there are some high level apis for
example the uri
class is there which can be used to
represent a
universal resource identifier as
specified in the rfc
and this is just an identifier this
doesn't provide
the means to access the resource if you
want to access the resource
then you need to use url which is the
class representing the
universal resource locator which is a
slightly older concept than uri
but with url you can hold the address as
well as access the address
url connection is also one of the class
which is created from the url class to
set up a communication link with the url
and similarly http url is for an http
connection and you have protocol
handlers there are a lot of interesting
classes
which you can explore if you want to
learn more about
what all networking support java
provides but when we talk about the
basic ones like ipv4 address the url uri
classes
these are the ones which generally most
developers interact with
if you want to write a socket
programming uh socket program that's
used you can still do that
with the classes and interfaces support
provided by java
so you can see bunch of interfaces here
key policy
socket option then in terms of classes
you can see again content handler cookie
manager
http cookie i need four and i need six
address with the classes which i talk
about
it also has a generic class but i would
always recommend to use one of these
if you know what address you are dealing
with uh the url connection the jar url
connection class proxy class
some bunch of socket classes uri url
classes
and some enums and exceptions as well
which are related to networking
connections
for example malformed url if the url
itself is
is not correct then you get a malformed
url exception
socket exception if there's a socket
timeout exception then also you have a
dedicated exception for that
so there are a bunch of different
exceptions uh classes
enums and interfaces available which you
can have a look at
if you want to dig deeper into it so
i've also prepared a demo where we will
be using some of these functionalities
of these of this particular package so
let's jump to the ide and see what i've
built
so here i have created a class called
networking demo
and what we are trying to do that we
will provide the simply launch url
and we will try to get bunch of
information
about how this website is hosted so
you just create a simple string variable
and you can type any string you can
write
any favorite website of your choice here
and then
we create the inet address class and
like i said you always use the concrete
implementation of the inet address class
which is in this case inet 4 address so
i use the get by name and we supply the
url
to get an inet address object
and what does inet address contains it
contains all the information in terms of
the internet
address on which that particular website
is hosted
so you will see lot of different
functionality in this class
let's explore some of the functionality
and methods which are provided by the
inet address class so
once you do this you will get an inet
address address object if the url is
correct if the url is incorrect you will
get
a malformed url exception anyways if you
want to just see the address
of the ip address where this particular
website is hosted
you can call the get address method and
if you want to see the host address
method
then you can call the get host address
now you might be wondering what is the
difference between get address and get
host address
so let's get first that out let me
comment the rest of the code
and let's first focus on this particular
part
so let me comment the local address part
as well
we will come to that in a while and i
can just remove this comment
so we are printing the get address and
the get host address and let's see what
values do we get
and how do we see if it's a different
value so this explains right
when we call init address dot get
address we just
get all the values as we know that when
we deal with ipv4 address the address
has four values
something dot something dot something
dot something if you want to verify it
just
go to your own laptop and you you will
be able to see some address like
192.168.something or something
so that uh so for ivv4 address has four
sections and all the four sections will
have some values
so if you use the get address method and
you try to convert this into a string it
basically will return an array the get
address method will return an array
which will look like
this but if you want to see it exactly
in the format
in which the real world networking
protocols understand it
then use the get host address which is
going to show it exactly in the way
in which we write the ip address where
we write some integer
dot some integer dot some integer dot
sum integer
so that's the difference between get
address method and get host address
method
same value different representation the
next function which i'm going to talk
about is about
local address and the local address or
the method name is
is any local address so this method is
going to tell me
if there is a wildcard address which is
associated with this particular host
you can also see what this method is
doing from the documentation
so if you go to the documentation and if
you search for this particular method
in the inet 4 address class you will see
it says utility routine to check if the
inet address
is a wild card address the result will
be a boolean which will indicate if it
has a wildcard
address or not so let's run this program
and understand if it has a wildcard
address
no there is no wildcard address
associated for this particular website
similarly there is another method which
we can explore which is is
link local address so let's search for
the documentation of it first
so this is the class if you search it it
will just show you the exact class which
is present with the method
and this method provides basically a
check
to see if the inet address is a link to
a local address within the domain of the
website
so the result again will be a boolean if
it says true it means there is a link to
the local address
and if it returns false it means the
address is not
a link local unicast address so
let's see the output of this in with
respect to the simply learned website
so if i run this program now i again get
false so there is no wildcard address
attached or associated with the website
and it does not point to a local unicast
address either
is there a loopback mechanism now these
all are networking concepts and uh since
this is not a networking session so i
will not go deeper into what
what a loopback address means in detail
but to get
to give you an understanding of where it
present and how you can use this in java
is what we are going to focus on
so if you want you can always read about
what is a loopback address
but if you want to know if the url which
you are pointing to
is uh the address which is returned by
that website
has a loopback address or not then you
can use the is loopback address method
and this again returns true or false
based on whether it has a loopback
address
or it does not have a loopback address
so if i run this particular program
we get the output false again so no it
the simplylink website does not even
also have a
loopback address the last one or the
second last one which i want to explore
is the site local address method so
let's see what does
this method do let me just remove this
extra commented lines
so let's look at the documentation of
this method
so this is a utility routine to check if
the init address
is a site local address the result is a
boolean
indicating if the init address is a site
local address or
false if the address is not a cyclical
site local
unicast address again this concept is
again
a networking special concept for similar
to the loopback address
so this is just basically showing if the
site also has
a uh basically a local unicast address
associated with it or not
so if you want to see the site local
address output i have enabled that code
and if you run this particular program
we get false for that as well yes that
means that the the
simple website is built with pretty good
practices there is no loopback address
there is no site local address which we
don't need
for for this particular website in this
case the last one is just
a simple thing just to see the hash code
it's not much of
relevance mostly the programs but just
to tell you that this is also available
so you can also see the hash code which
is contained by the inet address
object so we covered bunch of
functionality in this particular example
we had a look at the java.net package it
has an inet 4 address class and i net 6
address class
lot of networking exceptions and
interfaces support as well
and the simple way to use it is to you
point it to a website
call the get by name call the get host
address and you will get the ip address
in the exact format in which the
networking world
deals with it similarly you can call the
get address to
just get an array of it just as we saw
here
and then there are a lot of utility
functions available in the inet address
class like
is any local is link local is loop back
his site local
and there are actually more if you look
at this class you will find more methods
here
uh in terms of what like for example it
also has a is multicast address
this is basically to check if the init
address is an ip multicast address
so there are a lot of different methods
here there are some mc methods as well
which will check
which are specially created for the
multicast address scenarios
so a utility routine to check if the
multicast address has a global scope
if it has a local scope or sorry it has
a node scope basically
or it has a link scope or it has a site
scope
so there are a lot of different methods
available for the multicast as well
which you can have a look at and we
already covered the get address
the get host address and the hash code
address classes there are some url
classes as well like i mentioned url ui
classes are also very important classes
which you might need to use whenever you
are you are building
a connection with a particular
application based on their url
if you are doing socket programming
there are socket classes available which
you can also use
while using the networking concepts in
java so you can build a pretty
decent and robust application uh using
the networking classes and the
networking support provided by java to
build
a networking application let's get
started with
image handling in java so we deal with
images on a daily basis
and you will often be required to deal
with image handling in java programs as
well
where you might need to re read an image
or write an image
or load an image into memory and do
other kind of manipulations
on the images so java does provide
support for image handling as well
and you can pretty much load up
any type of image be it a gif image a
beta png or be it a
jpeg image basically it converts into a
java 2d
image to render it and it basically
creates a byte representation of the
image to serve and save the contents
so in this section we are going to talk
about the image handling aspects of java
and to do that there are broadly two
classes which java provides
as you can see in this official
documentation the first one is
java.awt.imageclass
and the second one is
java.awt.image.bufferedimageclass
which extends the image class so this is
basically the superclass as
you can see here which you can use to
represent any kind of graphical image
as a 2d array of pixels and buffered
image is a concrete implementation of
the image class
which you can use to construct instances
of the class and
buffered images is sort of the i would
say the defacto standard or the go to
class whenever you are dealing with
any kind of image rendering tasks in a
java program
and we will also have a look at how we
can use the buffered image class
to basically read and a sample image
and also write a sample image to a file
system
so you can read more about this in the
documentation and
these are there are also bunch of
documentations available in terms of how
you can read it how you can load it into
the program
how you can draw an image how you can
create and save the image etc
and like i mentioned we will be covering
some aspects of it
in today's demo as well so this was a
very brief theoretical introduction
about image handling
and like i always mentioned if you want
to know more about this
do check out the official documentation
of of java where you can learn more
about
the image handling classes and utilities
so with that
let's move to the demonstration part so
i have prepared a demo here
which talks about image handling so i
have created a class called image
handling demo
which has a public static void main
method and
i'm just giving some some sample uh
dimensions for the image in terms of
width and height here
and then as i mentioned that we will be
using the buffered image class
so i'm creating an a reference for the
buffered image it's currently assigned
to null so basically there's nothing
and then i am calling the method read
from file
so like i mentioned you can you mostly
will be dealing with reading from an
image or writing to an image so here we
will look at both of the aspects as to
how you can
load an image from your file system into
a java program
and then write it back to the file
system from your java program
so let's first look at the read from
file method which will tell
us how we can read a java file so i
provide some sample dimensions these
dimensions will vary based on your use
case
and i supply the buffered image object
inside that i have created a try block
and in the try block the first thing you
need to do for image handling is to
basically create a file object
because image is also technically just a
file right
so you provide the file image path here
at this particular location
so let's go to the sample image part
this is the destination
path and let me open the sample image
path as well which is
somewhere in the c drive so this is the
image which we are loading this is the
path which i have mentioned which is
c sample dot jpg so let's first have a
look at the image
as well as to what this image contains
so this image is basically from a from a
click
clinical trial and showing some blood
sample or some vaccine bottles
which is probably the very uh popular
image nowadays because we are living in
this pandemic world
so this is the sample image which i have
chosen to read and then i will
load this into the java program and then
we'll try to write it back to the file
system
to a destination location so this is
where my image is present in the c drive
named with sample.jpg
and this is what i've supplied here so
you just need to supply it in double
quotes
remember when you're dealing with
windows file system
you always have to use double forward
slashes which is different if you're
working with a on a mac machine or
you're working on a linux system where
only this will work fine so that's a bit
awkward thing
which which windows has and you have to
respect the operating systems
uh restrictions or way of doing things
so once you have loaded the file or
created the sample.jpg file object
then the next thing we are going to do
is we are going to create an
object of the buffered image remember we
just created a reference we did not
create an
object yet of the buffered image class
and now is the time to do that
so we supply the width we supply the
height and then we supply the type of
the image
let's go to the constructor of this
image to see what this image type means
so this image type can be basically the
type of the created image which
comes from the color space so whether
it's an rgb image or a rgb image or bgr
image or a bite gray image there are
multiple different types of images in
the media space
and whatever type of image you have you
need to basically supply that image type
in this particular argument so in my
case it was an argb image so i supplied
that particular
if you click on this you will see that
currently it's inside java
an 8-bit rgba image basically has a
static constant which is
denoted by two you can read more about
this inside the buffered image class
documentation is
as well so once i've supplied that my
buffered image
object is ready which has all the
details
dimensions and the types of the image
now the next thing is that you need to
fill this image
object with the file so you basically
need to read the file
and store the output of this read
operation into the
buffered image object then what will
happen that along with this information
whatever is present here will also be
added to the same buffered image object
so to read a image or simple a file
java provides an i o utility which is
called image i o
and there is a read method available
which is a static method on this
particular class as you can see i'm
calling the class dot method name here
and then you supply the sample file name
once you have done that
then it will basically be reading the
whole image into a 2d byte array and
copying that over into this buffered
image
object once that is done if this
particular line is successfully executed
then you will get this message which
will say reading complete and it will
try to print
some hash code of the image object and
after that if
there's any exception in this block for
example this particular line
may raise an exception or this
particular line may raise an exception
if the file does not exist
then you need to have the io exception
caught remember io is a checked
exception
so if you are using these operations
file new file and imageio.read
you need to catch the i o exception
because it's a checked exception so
either you need to catch it
or you need to rethrow it these are the
only two options you have with the
checked exception so once we have done
all of that if everything goes
fine if everything is happy till line 35
then we just return the image object
and our read from file operation will be
done going back to the main method
once the read operation is done the next
thing i'm going to do is
writing this image object to a new
destination file
so let's see what is happening in this
write to file method because this is the
method which is responsible for writing
this image to a new destination location
so i've created a public static void
void method inside the same class where
the public static void main method is
present
as you know that static methods can only
call other static methods
that's why this has this had to be
static and i'm supplying the same image
object which was returned from the read
operation that goes in as the argument
of this particular method
and again i'm using a file object and
this time i'm providing a destination
location
where i would like to write this image
so this is the destination location i've
chosen which is
f drive java tutorials folder and the
image should be stored with the name
out dot jpg so this is the location
there's already already an out.jpg here
so let me just remove it so that we can
observe the output
so we create the file object after that
we again use the image i o utility uh
we call our static method static utility
method called write
we supply the whole image object we
supply
the image type extension and we supply
the output location
again if i take you to the signature of
this you take the rendered image
you take the format name which is jpg
and the output location so these are the
three things which you need to supply
once you call the right method on the
image io utility class
image io is a very handy class and do
remember this class whenever you are
dealing with
the image handling operations it will
provide lot of static convenience
methods
so we write this file uh write this
image object to a file to a destination
location
and if everything goes fine in these two
lines we will get this message which
will say writing complete
if anything goes wrong we again catch
the i exception and the exception will
be printed here that's all is happening
in this particular program where we are
reading from file
and we are writing to the file reading
it from here and writing it
on this particular location so let's run
this program and see if we are able to
read from file successfully and also
write it to the specified location
so run as java application it's a
slightly memory heavy operation so it
takes a bit of time because
the whole image needs to be loaded into
memory be very careful about that it
might eat up your
a large portion of your ram if the image
is too heavy so here it says reading
complete
and then it prints the hash code details
of this particular object
and then it also executed the write to
file method and it said writing complete
so just to show you the reference back
again this is what we
read sample.jpg and c drive and if i go
to the f drive
java tutorials where i provided the
output location i do see an outdoor jpg
here which which was not there earlier
and if i double click on this
it's exactly the same image so java was
able to
read the image and render the exact same
image by converting the 2d byte
array representation back to an image
exactly the same
for there's no change in this image so
this was a very short enlightening
tutorial for you to
show you how you can use image handling
classes for example the image io class
and the buffered image class
to do basic image handling operations
obviously you can do more complex
operations with it as well
but for the demonstration purpose i've
just kept it simple let's get started
with concurrency utilities in java
now concurrency is a huge topic and it's
not possible to cover this into a 10 or
15 minutes tutorials
so treat this particular session as an
introductory session
where i will talk about some of the most
relevant classes
which you need to know when you talk
about concurrency
we have been talking about this whole
concept of concurrency programming
throughout the
thread tutorials as well and the basic
idea is
that you would like to do multiple
things at the same time
that's the basic idea now in that
context java does provide lot of
utilities and packages
especially the java.util.concurrent
package
is one of the most popular package which
you need to use whenever you are dealing
with
concurrency programming paradigms in
java so
with that let's have a look at what does
this java.util.concurrent package
contains
so broadly it contains lot of utility
classes
which can be very useful for you when
you are writing the concurrent
programming code apart from that it will
also provide some basic ideas around the
locking functionality and the atomic
packages as well
when we talk about locks again we
discussed about locks when we talked
about the
whole sync thread synchronization
concept as well and
it basically marries very well with the
whole concept of locks
and atomic packages as well atomic is
again a different topic which
is used for thread safe types basically
but whenever you will hear about
concurrency utilities be it in your
discussions or be it in your interviews
you will be seeing a discussion
happening
around executors you will hear these
terms like executors
executor service future completable
future
callable all of these you will hear the
name of all of these classes quite
frequently
so we these classes were first
introduced in java 8 and have been there
since then
to support the concurrency programming
paradigm so i will talk about these
three classes broadly in today's session
and we'll
have a look at a demonstration of these
three classes as well uh let's first
talk about executor
technically it's an it's an interface
it's not a class though i said that it's
a class but it's basically an interface
an executor is basically a very simple
interface which will help you define the
sub systems which you want to which you
would like to create with the help of
threads
may be including thread pools or if you
want to do
a disk reading and writing operation in
an insynchronous way or you want to
create some sequence of task frameworks
as well
so executor will provide you a very
lightweight framework to do all of that
especially around thread pooling and
asynchronous io is is where it shines
most because in your computer you have
limited resources
and you would like to dedicate a certain
pool of threads for a particular task or
for a particular executor
object so with that and the second class
which we would like to know about is
executor service
an executor service will provide a more
asynchronous
task execution framework and this is
probably the class which you will be
using
whenever you're dealing with
asynchronous programming in java
asynchronous programming basically means
that
you submitted a particular task but you
did not wait for
it to be completed you did not hang your
process or your thread
for that particular task to be completed
it's very simple it's very uh
easy to relate this to a real life for
example if you are
you know there are times when you do two
things at the same time for example
uh let's take a very very simple example
if you're just boiling milk
on on your gas stove so you put the milk
on the gas stove
and then you move out for a couple of
minutes to do some something else
for example maybe checking your mobile
for new emails or or doing some other
work doing maybe just
doing some laundry so uh you are doing
the you you submitted the milk boiling
task
then you moved away from that task
because you know that this particular
task is going to take some time
and you utilize your time somewhere else
that's what we mean by asynchronous
programming and executor service
will provide you with constructs to
create a similar behavior
in your java program as well so remember
about executor and executor service
we will look at the implementations
later where we can talk about that
another interesting class which i would
like which i would like to talk about is
future if we have it here yeah so future
is another class which we will be
looking at and future is basically uh
to fetch the result of the submitted
task
again taking the same knife example of
the milk milk boiling example
so it would be great right if if there
is some mechanism
or some alarm which just sets off the
moment
the milk is is is boiling and it's about
to be spilled out
it would be great to know that in that
in advance via some alarm or something
so future provides that kind of a
carrier or that kind of a
holder where you submitted a particular
task you moved your threads to something
else
you did something else and then you can
check with the future object and future
object will tell the status of their
submitted task whether it is completed
or whether it's still in progress
once it is complete then you can fetch
the result of that submitted task
based on with the future object so
that's the concept of future so remember
executor service and future
they will work quite hand in hand
because executor service will be used to
submit the task and future will be able
to fetch the result
of that particular task asynchronously
so that was about a quick theory
you can read more about it in the
documentation you can see an executor
service
uh future class what does what does this
basically in this class do
uh but to have a look at or get a
greater sense of this let's have a look
at our demonstration of it to
understand these classes better so let's
move to
the eclipse ide to look at an example
let me close all the classes and just
open a relevant one
so yeah so let's first deal with the
executor
interface itself so if i just minimize
this one
here i've created a main class and i've
created a public static void main method
and you see two static methods here
executor invoke and executed service
invoke i'm basically showing you how you
can use executor and executor service
so if you're just using executor then
how you would do that is basically
you are going to create a reference of
the executor
and then the executor needs a basically
an executor object because it's an
executor reference so you need to supply
an executor object
so either you can supply an inner class
right here
or you can call you can create a
executor type of class which i've
created here which is called caller
class
so i've created a class called caller
which implements the executor type
and execu the moment you write
implements executed it will force you to
override the execute method and inside
the execute method you are going to run
your own thread so this is how the
current thread or the executor's
own thread will be running so once you
have done the initialization
then you can call the execute method on
the executor class
remember you got this object so you can
call the executor
execute method on the executor object
here and inside this
you can provide this particular lambda
function implementation
which is going to ask you what exactly
you want to do
when i run this particular thread so
when i run this thread
when java runs this particular thread
what do you want java to do
that's something which you will provide
here so this is how you can use
it's a very simple example like i said
this if i build a more complex example
it will take a lot of time and lot of
other concepts to cover
so treat this as an introductory session
and you can basically try to run a very
simple example of this
writing whatever complex logic you want
to write while the thread is running
and put that into this execute similarly
if you if you want to use
executor service for doing the
asynchronous operations
then it will follow the same way but
there are some differences along the way
as well
so this is the method which is showing
the executor service implementation or
the way of using executor service
so again i create a reference of
executor service and then here
you see i'm saying executors dot new
fixed thread pool with a size of 10. so
that's the power of executor service it
is going to
create a pool of threads dedicated to
itself to do the tasks whichever are
written
inside here so whatever you write here
these thread pool will be utilized to
execute that particular task you can
assign the size of the thread pool based
on how many threads you need there are
multiple
static utility methods like there is one
new fixed thread pool which i've used
but if you just do control enter you
will see cached thread pool
a single thread execution a new work
stealing pool
so like i mentioned there are a lot of
classes interesting classes here which
you can use
for simplicity i've just used a fixed
thread pool here once you get the
executor service object
then here you called execute but here
you will be calling the submit method
and then the drill goes
exactly the same way that you write the
lambda function
implementation inside here basically the
functional interface implementation
and you provide your own implementation
code which you would like to
run whenever you call the run method
whenever this executor service calls the
run method on that particular thread you
can actually go to the submit method and
you will see it accepts a runnable it
basically accepts a thread object so
whatever you write inside this
particular code
will be the public void run
implementation of that particular thread
class
if you don't if you don't remember how
threnable works please go back to my
threading
tutorial and watch that where i
explained the runnable
interface and the run method in detail
so that's what we are doing here
so this is for executor and this is for
executor service so let's run this
program
and yes i mean nothing because i'm not
doing anything much apart from just
doing sis
outs here and that's what you see here
the executor's example and the executor
service exam
so this was about executor and executor
service now let's deal with another
interesting uh class of
of called future which i said that i
will also talk about so for that i have
created a separate demo because
it deserves a separate demo it's a very
interesting class so let me just
make it full screen yeah so i've created
a class called future demo
which has a public static void main
method and again i'm doing the
executor service initialization but this
time i'm using a new single thread
executor
now what does this does this this will
basically create an executor which will
use a single worker thread
operating from an unbounded queue
remember
even if this single thread terminates
due to let's say a failure during the
execution
before the before the graceful shutdown
a new one will automatically
be spawned and will take its place if
the execution is still pending so that's
the power of single worker thread from
an unbounded queue
that's what i've used here based on your
use case you can use other ones as well
like i mentioned earlier
then uh i have the executor service
object with me
and similar to the previous example i'm
going to call the submit method
and inside the submit method i need to
provide the runnable class
runable interfaces implementation and
that implementation will basically be of
the
public void run method and this is what
i want to do in my run method where i'm
sleeping the thread for 10 seconds
thread.sleep method takes milliseconds
values as the parameter
so this is 10 000 which means 10 seconds
so i'm sleeping this thread or pausing
this thread for 10
seconds and then returning a string
called completed
this is what i am doing in the executor
service dot submit
implementation the result of it is going
to be
a future object remember the result of
the submit task
is going to be a future object so i
store that future reference here
and then at line 20 i'm using the same
feature or
future object to ask java to check if
this task is done and the way you do
that is just by calling is done
so till the time there is a negation
condition till the time the task is
still in progress
because this main future is not done
because i've put a negation
then just print this out there where you
say the task is still in progress it's
still not complete
and you pause this particular thread
remember this was a different thread
if you you pause this particular thread
for 500 millisecond or basically
half a second and you again check this
condition if it's still
not done you print this again pause for
half a second again check this
till the time feature dot is done
becomes true
when future dot is done becomes true
that means that this particular
task is completed now you see i mean
generally when we execute the programs
the execution happens sequently
sequentially that after line 17 the
control will automatically flow to line
20
and before the control can reach line 20
everything
above line 17 has to be completed that's
that's
basically synchronous programming for
you but when you talk about asynchronous
programming
using the power of executor service and
future objects
we can do something here which will go
into a separate thread
and then you can continue your execution
here so this can be in a different
method altogether
where you submit something and this is
basically checking the status of
this task understand this very well this
is very important concept that it's not
as
it's though it's a sequential execution
after line 17 line 20
is getting executed but line 20 is not
waiting
for everything above line 17 to be
finished it will continue that's the
power of asynchronous programming so
here we are checking this
and once the feature the future dot is
done says true
then we say task completed we and then
you probably would like to fetch the
result of this particular task right
and for that future provides a method
called future dot get
this is going to pick the future object
state and whatever you are returning
from here
will be returned here and then i'm
printing the result so if everything
went fine this result should say
completed because that's what i'm
returning from
this future object and always remember
to shut down your executor service to
release the thread pool which you
created here i've also put a catch block
here
because i'm using the thread.sleep
method which will ask you to handle an
interrupted exception and then there is
an executor service exception which is
execution and a timeout exception as
well
there are other interesting methods as
well on the future class future object
sorry which is like future.cancel where
you can cancel explicitly a future
task which is currently in progress you
can check the status of it
by calling is done which i've used here
you can also call is cancelled to check
if the user or
some other process explicitly canceled
the execution
of the submission of the executor
service task
so hope this is you are able to
understand the flow of it that these
block and these block will program will
execute them but they will run in
different threads so let's see what
happens
now i'm going to run this particular
program and if i bring this here you see
the task still in progress
keeps getting called so we submitted the
task here
and now this block is getting executed
this block uh kept getting executed so
this task did not finish right the
thread dot sleep was this this thread
this whole
thread was sleeping for 10 second but
line 20 did not wait for 10 seconds it
continued execution
and it kept checking the future object
10 times at least
or till the whole 10 second sleep was
taken away
and one once that once this thread woke
up it returned completed
feature dot is done became true and it
came out and it said task completed
so that's what we get here and at the
end in the result you get completed
which
is which is what you returned from here
so this is the power of
asynchronous programming please like i
mentioned please do read about more
about
these classes and how they work and what
is the paradigm of asynchronous
programming
it does make debugging a bit hard at
times but it's a very interesting
concept to be used
in concurrent applications let's get
started with regular expressions
or regex in java you may hear people
calling it as
as regex or regex doesn't matter you can
call it anything as
as you want till the time you have the
concept understood in the right way
i'll just call it as regex so when we
talk about regex
let's understand why do we need them and
what are how java actually provides
support for that so the basic idea
behind
regular expressions is is to find a
pattern
in a in a text corpus if you have lot of
strings available if you have any kind
of text any kind of string
and if you would like to find a
particular pattern saying okay
does this whole text paragraph contains
any character
or contains any number or contains any
special characters
or contains characters after numbers or
numbers after characters
so if you would like to find those kind
of patterns in
in your text corpus then you can then
that concept is called regular
expression
finding and java provides the support
for that particular
regular expression finding through a
package called java dot util
dot regex package so this is the package
which you would need to use
when you want to do any kind of regular
expression finding in that text
now you may want you may be thinking
that why do i need to use this
i already have the string handling
methods right you can do substring you
can find
a particular character in the string etc
but that is limited
because it only and only provides string
methods
ways to manipulate and find and replace
strings but regex is
generic you can literally find any kind
of character
in your string it can be a special
character it can be a square bracket it
can be a multiply sign
it can be a divide sign it can be like i
said integer uh
capital letters small case letters so
any kind of pattern you would like to
find
java.util.x can be used to find that
kind of pattern
now this package is very interesting and
it provides lots of classes
and again this is a very very very big
topic and
very complex topic so we will just
scratch the surface of it
and like i always say whenever you would
like to read more about it
go back and read the documentation
currently the documentation i've opened
is for
version 8 but when you are reading it
you can go for the latest
java edition uh documentation so with
that
let's talk about some of the interesting
classes which we will be dealing with
and we must know when we talk about
regex in java so i already explained
what are regular expressions
let's go to the interesting classes the
first class which we need to
know about is the pattern class so
pattern class or an object of the
pattern class will basically be
representing
a compiled regular expression so you
write your regular expression
in a certain way regular expression has
its own language i would say
to write the pattern for example if you
would like to write a pattern saying
that
find uh check if this particular text
paragraph
has the characters first then the
integers then the characters then this
particular special character so that is
your pattern
you write that pattern then you need to
compile that pattern to compile that
pattern
you can use the pattern class this this
class generally does not provide any
kind of
public constructors to you so you cannot
initialize the pattern
object explicitly but to create a
pattern you first you need to basically
call the static methods
a static method named as compile so
compile is the method which you need to
use to compile your regular expression
which will then return the pattern
object once you have compiled your
written your pattern and you compile
your pattern the next class which you
need to
know about is the matcher class matcher
class will provide that particular
engine framework which will understand
and interpret the pattern
and then will try to find that pattern
on the text paragraph which you are
supplying
and it will result in true or false if
it finds that pattern it will say true
if it's not finding the pattern it will
say false so that's the basic idea so
you need to you need to know about the
pattern class and you need to know about
the matcher class
so it also does not the matcher class
also does not provide any kind of public
constructors
and you obtain a matcher object by
calling the matcher method
on the pattern option so once you
created a pattern object
just call the matcher on that particular
object and that
will get you a matcher object and it
then you can use that object to find the
patterns in that particular
text corpus there is also a dedicated
exception which is called pattern syntax
exception which will be thrown whenever
you have written the regular expression
syntax incorrectly like i said it has
it has its own language so you need to
write the expression in a way
regular expressions are supposed to be
written and supposed to be
understood i will touch upon that in a
while but that's that's the basic idea
about the three classes
now when when you would like to find a
pattern it can be a string pattern it
can be some characters it can be some
predefined characters
some quantifiers you can also create sub
groups
within the regular expression so there
is a like i said there is a tons of
functionality which is available in this
particular
concept and we will just cover some of
the relevant ones or just just run
through
some of these concepts and then i will
switch to a demonstration
for example if you talk about the string
literals then you can
do the string matching for example if
you want to find this particular
word or this pattern this is just a text
pattern right so if you would like to
find this particular text pattern
in the text string then you can write
this
particular text pattern as a string
pattern inside
the pattern object so that's that's
about the string literals
now let's move to some interesting ones
like uh like meta characters
and the meta characters are very
interesting because they have a special
meaning
for example if you write your regular
expression like this where you say
cat and then you say dot then when you
are applying this particular
regular expression to find the match
into a string
it is only going to find the match for c
a t
it is not going to find the match for c
a t dot
because dot is a meta character in
regular expression
it has a special meaning it does not
mean dot
but it has a special meaning and that
special meaning basically means that
even though the dot is not present it
will basically mean that
after cat it can be any character so the
meta character dot means
any character which is why you see this
snatch succeeds because
it will search for this pattern which it
matches and after that
it can be any character it doesn't care
so even if it's s or d
or whatever it will say true because c a
t was found a match
so dot means any character after the
pattern you have specified
similarly there are lot of other
characters special characters or meta
characters like the ones which have been
listed here
question mark star plus dot on and all
of these have their own dedicated
special meaning
they are not your your normal uh
arithmetic operators or other operators
they have their special meaning when you
are
dealing with meta characters so do read
about them in detail and i will be using
a bit of meta characters in the example
as well
then the character classes are also very
interesting uh similar to the example
which i told you before if you want to
find
a particular string or a particular
integer into a
into a text corpus then you can use the
character class patterns
for example you just put a square
brackets and you write abc
this means that it will try to find
exactly a b c
in the string if you put a cap in front
of abc then it will try to match any
character or find any character
except a b or c so it's a negation
similarly if you specify small a to z
and capital a to z
it means any character can be there
between small case a to z
and capital case a to z a to z inclusive
similarly you can provide specific
ranges like a through d
or m through p so only the characters
which will match the union of this
condition
will be returning true and rest of the
if that if this particular
pattern is violated then you will get
false so similarly there are
you can build lot of complex
combinations and permutations with these
special meta characters and character
classes do read about these in detail if
you are curious to know about it and
there is tons of materials available
on this on internet which you can read
about to learn more about
similarly there are predefined character
classes as well dot
is something which i already explained
which means any character
then you can use slash d to find a digit
in a particular string or
a particular text corpus slash capital d
is for non-digit or you can use the
classic negation condition as well
slash s is for a white space character
slash capital s
is for a non-white space character word
non-word so there are a lot of
different examples so i think by now you
would have built a decent understanding
of what i'm trying to tell you is that
you can specify these patterns compile
them and then use the matcher
so let's move to a very simple
demonstration it's not a complex example
but very simple example just to get the
point across
so i'm creating a regex string here and
this is the pattern i've specified i'm
saying
any character star means any number of
characters so it can be anything here
then the string the the pattern expects
an alphabetical uh string or
alphabetical section
after that the alphabetical section
should be followed by
a numerical section and after the
numerical section again it can be any
character
so this is my pattern i create a simple
string with this regex pattern
and like i mentioned in the
documentation you call pattern.compile
to compile the regular expression so i
compile the regular expression i get the
pattern object
and after again as per the documentation
it said that you can call the matcher
method
on the pattern object to get a matcher
object so i say pattern
dot matcher and i provide my string on
which i want to test it so i've just put
a random string where there are some
integers
then there is some alphabets and then
again there are some integers
once you have got the matcher object
just call matcher.find
this will return a boolean where you can
test whether
the the matcher found a hit in the text
corpus or not if it found a match
the match found will be true and if it
didn't found
find the match you will get a false
value in this result
so with that understanding let's run
this program so i get the output match
found
why did i get that because i said that
start with anything so it started with
anything i don't care what it is it's an
integer or
any special character i don't care after
that there should be some
alphabets so there are some alphabets
and right after alphabets there should
be some numbers so again there are some
numbers
and after that there can be any
character 0 or more characters so there
is nothing here
that's why you see a match found let's
do an interesting test here
let me do this i put a to z again here
so now i'm saying start with anything
have alphabets
have numbers and again after numbers you
should have some alphabet which is not
the case here because you start with
something
you have alphabets you have numbers and
after numbers the string
ends there is nothing after that so
let's see what happens now you get a
match not found
because this particular pattern when got
compiled and got applied on this
particular string
did not find the string following the
right x pattern which you have specified
so this is a very simple example to show
you how you can build
patterns you can use groups concepts as
well to group the patterns
it can get very very complex and very
very nasty so
use them very wisely very carefully and
do read about the documentation and
other examples which i talked about
to get more understanding and more
comfortable with regex
let's get started with nio packages in
java now
let's first understand why why do we
need this package
and where will be using this package
let's talk about the wear first
you can use the nio package to read from
a file
or write to a file now let's talk about
the why
because the obvious question will be
that we already have the i o package in
java right where you can
where you can use the classes from that
particular package to
read from a file or write to a file then
why do we need
an another package doing exactly the
same thing as nio
so the basic reason for launching the
java.nio package
was providing the multi-threading
capabilities to the io library and we
could not do this in the existing io
library because we had to probably
rewrite and
change the functionality of it that's
why java created a new library called
new package called java.nio package and
this package
is basically uh i mean if you if you
understand what nio means here
generally as per the popular perception
it means non
blocking io that you don't want to block
your threads while you're reading to a
file or writing to a file
classically niu meant networking i o
but as per the popular perception people
know is know it as
non-blocking i o so the basic idea is
because whenever you are read
reading a file or writing to a file the
thread gets
blocked until the whole file is written
or until the whole file is
read so the nio package provides an
improvement over that
it provides an improvement in a way that
you can read the file into a different
thread
but at the same time move on to another
thread and writes to a file
so you get this multi-threading
capabilities and non-blocking
capabilities out of the box
from the classes provided by java.nio
package
so that's the brief about this package
now some of the popular classes which
you will be dealing with and
some of the concepts which you need to
know about niu package are
buffers and channels these this is
probably the core concept of the whole
nio package
of how channels and buffers work so
let's say you are trying to read
something
then the read operation will be
happening from the channel
into the buffer and similarly the write
operation will be happening in the
reverse way
which means to the channel from the
buffer so that's how the buffer and
channel work
together that whenever you are trying to
write something you have to first open a
channel
create a buffer and then you can read
from the channel into the buffer
and similarly when you're writing to the
buffer you again have to go via the
channel route
so channel is that route basically
buffer is basically just a plain
container for the data
and channel is basically representing
the connection
to the entities which are capable of
performing the io operation so think of
channels as
as a pipe a channel literally basically
if you if you understand the english
meaning of channel that's exactly what
we mean by here that it provides just a
means to an
end it provides sort of a wire to the
buffer
and then you also have selectors and
selection keys classes which together
with selection
channels work to provide the
non-blocking i o
functionality there are some other apis
interesting apis as well like cassette
and some more but i will not go into the
detail of that because
if you know about buffers and channels
and selectors then we will be able to
figure out what exactly we would like to
do with this
i would also like to talk a bit more
about the buffer class so if you go to
the buffer classes
operations the popular operations you
will see there will be the read
operation
which is for reading the files basically
or reading the content of the file this
works on the byte stream concept first
of all
so it to read the bytes from the file
you will call the read method there's
also a very interesting method called
flip which i will be using
which makes a buffer ready for the new
sequence of operations
so once you have done something and you
want to let's say you read a particular
file
and you have come to the end of the file
now you would like to reset
the buffer and go back to the beginning
of the file then you can use the flip
method for that particular
piece to the uh to bring the current
position back to the position
to the zero index or to the starting of
the file so
that's about read and flip and we will
have a look at some of the other methods
and there are lot of interesting classes
in this nio package
do read read about the documentation and
check out the other methods as well to
learn more about this package
but the basics are like i said channels
buffers
some methods of the buffers and there's
also a path class which is used to
basically
provide a particular path to a directory
which i will not be covering in this
example but something good to know so
with that understanding let's move to an
example and understand how we can
work around with this an io package so
for that i have prepared an example
where i will be writing a reading from a
file and then writing to a file
so i have a main method here the first
section here basically is about
reading from a file and the second
section is about
writing to a file so let's go through
all of both of these sections one by one
to understand what is happening
so in the read section i use the file
input stream class
from the i o package i'm still not using
the paths class here
just to show you that both two on both
of them still can work together
if you want to use the old constructs so
i use the same file input construct to
read a file called source.txt
which is present at this particular
location in my directory
and this source.txt has has just a one
line of text
nothing more so i i basically create the
file input stream object
and then i create a channel because we
are dealing with files so you create a
file channel if you're dealing with
network socket then you might have a
socket channel
so that's also something which you need
to know about that this nio package is
is generic it can be used for any kind
of communication
of reading and writing not specifically
to file handling so
we create a file channel object here by
calling file input stream
dot get channel it's that simple once
you call that you will get a reference
or the object basically of the file
channel
then the next thing is to create the
buffer like i mentioned that channels
and the buffer are the two
main tools through which you work within
an io library
so we create a byte buffer and we
allocate some starting size to it
just some some threshold size so you can
put it any number which
you think is practical for your file and
your for the use case
here i've put just one zero two four
bytes or one megabyte because
my file is pretty small so i just put
that and initialize that
read buffer and then i call read channel
dot
read operation so the file channel
object you created you just call the
read method on this particular channel
and supply the buffer and then it is
going to read the file
wire the channel into the buffer and
this read method is going to return a
result
to denote if the file was written
successfully or not
i'm just pointing printing assist out
here just a bear once this out nothing
new here
so this section will be used to read a
file so let's see if
i can read the file successfully and
then we'll move to the right section
so i go to run as java application yeah
it says file read successfully and it
read 27 bytes
it means that there were total of 27
bytes in my in my file
which had a single line of text so it
read all of that and it it completed the
execution
now let's move to the right section and
i can comment the read section
because we have covered that so here i'm
again creating a file output stream
object because i need to write something
so
again using the same construct of the i
o package i have covered previously
in the previous sessions once you have
the file output stream object created
the next thing is to create a channel so
i again create a file channel but this
time
it's the right channel i again create a
buffer which is the right buffer
allocate some size to it then this is
the string which i want to write to this
particular file
so my file my destination file will be
called dest.txt
will be present in this particular
location and this
file should have this string written if
this whole operation goes successfully
that's my end goal so to do that i say
right buffer dot put and whatever string
you have created
just call get bytes on it and you get a
bytes representation of the whole string
so that's what i've done here because
this put method expects byte because if
you go inside this
it expects a byte array so that's what
i'm supplying here i'm providing
the uh the byte array by on the string
by calling message.getbyte or any string
object.getbytes
will get your byte array once you've
done that then i'm calling the flip
method remember i talked about this flip
method to basically reset the index
that's something which you need to do in
this particular case so that the
index goes back to the initial position
and the buffer can be written
successfully to a file
uh to a channel basically so once the
buffer is comp
has completed its operation then i can
write the buffer to the channel
and once that is done then if those if
these operations went successfully
then i will see a file called dest.txt
in this particular directory currently
there is no desk.txt in this directory
you can see there are just three files
but there is no
test.txt so let's run this program so
it says file written successfully which
was the last sis out at line 28
but let's also see what is happening in
the directory
so now i see a desk.txt popping up here
it's a 1 kb file
and if i double click on this i see the
same string which is which say this
is a test string which is the same
string which i supplied here
so you can see you can use the nio
packages to do the file read and write
and much much more
than just read and write using the nio
package but this is just to get
get the point across that this can be
done using the nio or the non blocking
io package as well so that you get
maximum performance
on your machine while you deal with file
io operations
let's get started with java beans so we
have been creating java classes
and creating objects of those java
classes to work and manipulate
transfer data call methods create
properties
etc and java beans just use that
as the groundwork to create a
specification
first of all let's understand that java
beans is just a standard
it is just a specification which has
been provided by
by java to be followed while you are
implementing
production grade or enterprise grade
applications so it's just a pure
specification
set of standards if you want to read
more about this
please go to this particular link which
is written here i mean if you just
google java bean spec
oracle then you will be able to find
this particular link you will see a
download option here
if you go here you will get these two
specification documents option
so you can just accept the license
agreement and
click on this particular beans 0 1 1 0 1
pdf
and you can read about the whole java
bean specification
i have already downloaded this
particular pdf which is opened in this
tab
and if you go to the toc here it's an
official sun microsystem
white paper basically and if you read
about this
this is going to explain the whole java
beans api specifications it's going to
specify the core
components of the java beans component
architecture so it's a specification
let's understand that very well
if you go to the table of contents let's
go to the interesting one which says
what is
exactly a bean or a java bean so a java
bean is
basically a reusable software component
that can be manipulated
in any visual ide like eclipse or
intellij or netbeans etc
so technically a java bean is just a
java class
but that java class should follow three
main
properties the first property is that
that java class
should have getters and setters to
access the properties
second property is that that java class
should have
a public no argument constructor so that
anybody can create
an object of it and third is that
the java class should implement
serializable the reason
in java being specified these three
conditions which i said
so let's talk about the third one where
we are talking we are saying that it
should be
implementing serializable interface why
is that it's because
our java bean would be required to be
exported between applications
may be required to be written to a
database or to a file system
or to be converted into an xml or a json
document
sent over the network again being
deserialized so this will be moving
across
a lot because that's what we mean by
reusable
multiple different software components
and applications might be reusing that
bean again and again and that beat needs
to travel across
and to enable that that bean has to be
serializable because if you can't
serialize it you
just cannot transport that object to
another application it's just not
possible this is how java has been
so that's why you need to implement
serializable you need to have a public
no
argument constructor and you need to
have getters and setters
to access your properties you can
actually read more about this if you
scroll down
it will also talk about the difference
between beans and class libraries
remember not class but class libraries
and here it explains what i just said
that a java bean can have properties
it can have events and it can have
methods so properties are nothing but
the
normal attributes which you create
inside a java class nothing fancy the
same attributes are
named as properties for example you may
have a foreground property and then you
can have
a method which is just a normal java
method which can be called from other
applications
or from an environment and by default
all of the
bean's public methods will be exported
by exported i meant
when you export this when you serialize
and export this object
all the beans public methods will be
exported by default but
then a bean can choose to export only a
subset of its methods if
it wants to a bean can also have events
and events basically provide
a way for one object to notify other
objects that something has happened
so something similar to the uh to the
producer consumer example or the
producer consumer pattern
where you can notify other objects
threads also have this particular
pattern where a thread can notify other
threads that it has completed its task
and other threads can start
so ah so this is so that's the property
behind event where something has
occurred
and then the object can tell other
objects that's that that something has
occurred so that they can react
to that particular event so these are
the three main uh
traits which are properties events and
methods you can read more about this
particular white paper i will not go
into the details because it's a long
white paper
but it's a very well written white paper
which will give you a very good
understanding
of how java bean specification was
written what was the thought process
behind it
so coming back to the code if you want
to just write it it can be very simple
to write
just write any class and say implements
serializable so it will ask you to
provide a cl version uid
so you can write this here then you can
create your
attributes as normal private attributes
you can create
public methods to access and manipulate
these attributes in the forms of
getters and setters so these are the
public methods to
to access and manipulate these
attributes here we have a parameterized
constructor which will not be
required or which should not be there
when you're creating a java bean it
should just be like this because
when we talk about the public know args
constructor as we discussed in the very
first lectures that
you do not need to provide the default
constructor java will automatically
provide a default constructor for every
class
so you don't need to write something
like this it's just not needed because
you can write it but it has no value
attached it has no meaning because
this is something exact this kind of
code is already generated by java
compiler when it compiles this
particular class
so a public default no argument
constructor
implementing serializable private
properties and public methods
and you can have additional event
methods as well which i talked about
just when we were going through the
white paper and that's all pretty much
what a java bean is so you can see it's
it's just a java class but some
additional uh
specifications which a java class has to
follow to be called as
ajava bean let's get started with spring
framework
so spring framework is the most popular
web application framework available out
there today
and all of the big companies from
netflix to whatnot
use spring framework to build the modern
day java applications
so before we go any further let's
understand why do we need a framework
so let's understand this with the help
of a diagram so let me just
open a blank paint page and let me show
you what i mean by a framework and why
do we need this
so we built simple applications so far
but if you have to build a
enterprise grid web application you will
have a
front end probably where you will have
what you see in the browser so you will
have the html the javascript
or or any other java enterprise
edition classes like gsp servlet etc
then you will have a backend where your
java classes are present
which contains the business logic so the
business logic and then you have a
database
where you have the you store the basic
basically the whole
data so you have these three different
layers we also call this a
three tier architecture so you cannot
build all of this
by just using the core java classes
which we talked about
you need to do more integrations you
need to use
more different programming languages and
concepts to build a complete enterprise
grid application and if you try to build
all of this by yourself
then it's going to take a lot of time
and lot of effort that's why we have
frameworks
which basically create provide the
structure to create these three layers
so that's why we have this frameworks
and in the frameworks
spring is the most popular framework it
provides the
structure to write all these these three
layers one of the reasons i did not talk
about
the the java enterprise edition
technologies like
servlets and gsps because nobody works
on them today
even if you learn about servlet it's
good to know the conceptual
overview of servlets but nobody today
builds applications on jsps and servlets
that's the reason i did not talk about
it because today we have sophisticated
front end frameworks like
angularjs or react.js or amberjs and
whatnot and it is hydrating at a very
faster speed
so there is literally practically no
need for a java developer today to learn
about gsp
because i can bet you on that you can
take it in written for me
nobody is going to build the gsp app
based applications in 2021.
everybody is going to use some sort of
front-end framework to build that
and then you have a back end in the back
end you have the exact core java classes
like i just explained so you will be
using the java beans and
you will be basically using the pure
java concepts of collections
and and etc to write the backend logic
using the java classes and then you will
need a jdbc connection to
write to a database as well so you would
need a database as well and spring
provides connectors and
specifications to support all of these
three layers
that's the reason so generally when you
talk about a web application
let's talk about web application because
java primarily is used in web
applications
so in a web application you basically
see a browser window where
you load a particular page but what
happens behind the scene
this browser has some html and some js
maybe
and this code is basically calling some
end point this end point is present in
the
backend layer so this endpoint is
present in the backend layer
that end endpoint transfers the control
to the business layer
where you have your core business logic
written and then the business layer
transfers the control to the data layer
or some people also call it dow layer
this dow layer then talks to the
database that's how a web application
works
and that's what that's the architecture
you will mostly be following
whenever you are building any enterprise
grid application in any organization
so spring provides support for all of
these parts this obviously
is written by angular and react and
other frameworks but this is
this whole section is basically
presented or supported
by spring so with that let's understand
a bit more about spring framework
so if you go to the spring official
website it talks about some of the value
uh propositions spring is used heavily
like i said it's used
everywhere it's very flexible framework
there are a couple of concepts which
spring provides which is around
inversion of control and dependency
injection
and i will talk about these concepts in
a while uh
when we'll talk more about the springs
components it makes
uh it's quite productive and quite fast
as well so it's very fast to build
application on on spring
it has a whole dedicated security module
as well so it's quite secure by design
and the spring community is huge so you
can find lot of support on internet
let's learn bit more about the springs
core components or core technologies
so if you talk about the springs core
components these are the strings core
components
so you have a testing module you have
you have a core module first of all
inside the techno in the core components
you have a core module
which has ioc containers resources
events i'll talk a bit about that
it has a it has its own testing
component so it provides very good
support for testing applications
it has a data access component the data
access component is used to provide
connections
utilities to the database because like i
mentioned your application will be
talking to the database
and spring provides a a completely
dedicated component to be used whenever
you are dealing whenever you are talking
to the database
it also provides a web servlet component
to
provide support for spring mvc which i
will be covering in the next session
websockets and stomp and messaging
frameworks etc
it also supports reactive or
asynchronous programming if you want to
do that
it provides a lot of integration
capabilities in the integration modules
if you want to do jms or jmx or email
or task scheduling etc and it also
provides language support
to support international
internationalization of the applications
so it it has a lot of different
components but
we will focus on this core component
which is of the interest here so let's
talk about that
the first thing which you need to know
about string is
its support for inversion of control and
it provides that support by creating an
inversion of control container what do
we mean by inversion of control
the basic idea is let me take any random
example and i will be able to
communicate the idea behind this so
let's go to
any simple example which i have already
covered let's go to method calling for
example
so we had a student class we created a
student class
simple student class three properties
constructor and public getters and
setters
and then i created a main class and i
initialized the student object so to
the responsibility of creating the
student object
lies with the student class itself
student class have to be explicitly
initialized
to be having an object of the student so
this creates a problem because when
you're dealing with
enterprise grade frameworks you might
need to create a lot of objects on the
fly whenever the
end point is talking to the business
layer if i take the reference of this
architecture if the endpoint is talking
to the business layer classes business
layer classes are talking to the data
access layer classes
so when the business layer classes needs
to talk to the data access layer classes
the data access layer classes needs to
have an
object because that communication
happens between objects only
so who creates those objects if every
time the data access object has been uh
has been called and if we provide if we
pass that responsibility to the dow
class
to create the object or every time the
end point talks to the business class
we ask the business layer to create the
objects it becomes
a lot of painful process because every
time you will be doing this
new student everywhere you need a
student object which is very painful
process
so what spring says it says okay
involved the control of creating the
object so let's
not give the responsibility of creating
the object
to the class let's give that
responsibility to the framework
so the framework will be responsible for
creating the objects of a class
and it's not the class who will be
responsible for creating its own objects
so generally outside the framework a
class is responsible for getting its
object but
with spring spring inverts this
responsibility that's why we call it
inversion of control
the control is inverted it's reversed
and now it's the frameworks
responsibility to create
the objects you will also hear about a
concept called dependency injection a
lot
in context of ioc and dependency
injection is an
implementation of the ioc concept so
using
springs dependency injection mechanism
you can
inject the object of any class into any
class
once you do that spring dependency is
going to use the inversion of control
concept
and create the object that's about ioc
and di
or dependency injection then the other
modules like resources will provide a
way to
refer different files and properties if
you want to then you have a validation
module as well which will provide
different
validation constructs because once you
receive the data you might need to run a
lot of validation right
and writing the validation by yourself
can be very painful so it provides a
validation framework as well by
providing the validator interface
you can use this particular framework to
write the validation rules
checking the name not empty etc
similarly it also supports an expression
language
if you want to use that so the
expression language support is
wide very wide in fact you can create an
expression parser and you can do the
expression language evaluation
using the a spring expression language
similarly it also provides support for
aspect-oriented programming
now again all these concepts of
validation and spring expression
language and resource support
the you probably would need hours of
reading to learn about these concepts
and i'm just
running through them just to tell you
about these concepts and do read about
why do you need resources why do you
want to do validation
why do you need an expression language
what is aspect oriented programming
read about all of those concepts because
they are not related to java
they are generic concepts which will be
applicable to any programming language
so any enterprise application you build
in any programming language
you would need to do the validation you
would need to do the resource reference
management you would need to have an
expression language
you would need to have aspect oriented
programming support so this is just to
tell you that that java does provide an
aop or aspect oriented programming
support as well
and it has a lot of apis available for
that along with that it also provides
very good logging capabilities
because you definitely need to log all
the actions which the
framework or your objects are taking so
this was a very quick lightning overview
about spring
i understand it's not possible to cover
all the concept of a framework as
sophisticated and as smart as spring in
in 10 to 15 minutes lecture
so treat this as an introduction session
and like i said
read more about all of these components
i just explained the core because this
is this is sort of the main building
block of spring framework and then you
have other supporting
uh components as well so be do check out
the documentation
there are tons of examples available in
fact in the springs official website
itself
if you go to the spring guide section if
you go to the
learn and you go to the guide section
there are awesome getting started and
topical guides and tutorials available
so for example how to build a restful
web service how to schedule tasks
how to consume a restful web service how
to build a simple java project with
maven how to upload files with string
how to
do messaging with redis which is a
basically a caching framework how to do
messaging
using spring to rabbit mq rabbit mq is a
messaging framework so there are tons of
examples available here
very good documentation and very robust
documentation do check out the examples
to learn more about this
let's get started with mvc and the
implementation of
mvc using spring so before we go any
further
let's first understand what do we mean
by an mvc
application so in the previous lectures
i discussed about the three tier
application where you had a presentation
layer
you had a business layer and then you
had a database layer which is talking to
the database
and that's how we built a three-tier
application which can also evolve into
an
n-tier application but when when the web
development started
the most popular concept which came out
was
m v c m stands for
model v stands for view and c stands for
controller so the idea was that these
three components together
can render a web application and how
they render the web application
is basically that the controller is
going to receive the request
which is coming from the web browser
then the controller will have the
knowledge
of where the business logic for that
particular request
will be residing so the controller is
going to invoke
the model the corresponding model which
is required to execute the business
logic of the request
and the controller will also have the
knowledge of
what response page to be sent back to
the user
so we are talking about the response
page here not response
remember that because it's a web
application so the model view controller
architecture basically was designed
uh to keep in mind that you have a web
application where a request is coming
from
and you need to process some business
logic and then you need to return back
with a page response which is going to
be displayed on the web browser
of the client machine so that's why we
had these three components as model
view and controller controller taking up
the request then
finding the right model for it which can
execute the business logic
and then also finding the right view for
it which can render
the business logic processed by the
model so that's a quick
overview about model view controller or
mvc architecture
do read about it in detail to understand
how this works
but like i mentioned that mvc the most
popular mvc
implementation is provided by spring
spring
is the most popular mvc framework and
the way spring
implements it is something which i have
drawn already here so let's understand
how this works
so first the request comes from the web
browser and
spring has uh the a very first welcome
servlet which is called
dispatcher servlet any request which is
coming to the spring
enabled web application will first hit
dispatcher servlet
and once the request comes to the
dispatcher servlet the dispatcher
servlet has
all the knowledge of all the controllers
of all the view resolvers which i will
talk about in a while
and of all the views as well it also has
knowledge about handler mappings which
again i will just discuss now
so the basic premise is that dispatcher
servlet is
the component which has knowledge about
literally everything happening in your
application
and that's why dispatcher servlet is the
first
servlet or the first component which
receives your
web request so once the request comes
here first of all it looks at the path
and finds out the right handler for it
the right controller for it
and the way it does that by using the
handler mapping component or handler
mapping logic
which is provided out of the box by
spring framework so the handler mapping
logic will tell the dispatcher servlet
which particular controller is going to
process the request which is coming
because every request will have a
different controller return
so whatever the type of request is
whatever the path of the request is
based on that the dispatcher servlet is
going to find a particular
controller once the controller is found
like i mentioned earlier the controller
will have knowledge about
the right model to invoke for that
particular request
model is nothing but basically a java
class
holding the business logic for this
particular request
so it will invoke that java class and
get all the business logic processed
and then it is going to return a model
and
view object view is here simply
pointing to the ui response which you
are going to send back to the user
it can be a jsp page it can be an html
page it can be any other view technology
so anything which is which is used to
render a web application on a web page
is view and controller is going to send
both the model and view information back
to the dispatcher servlet
the dispatcher servlet will take the
view part of it and go to another
component which is again provided by
spring which is called view resolver
the view resolver will have the
knowledge to see
which particular actual jsp or
template to invoke for the view value
coming from the controller so based on
the value which is returned by the
controller a
view resolver is going to return the
right page
mapping and once the dispatcher servlet
knows the page mapping it is just going
to invoke that page by calling the view
component
so dispatcher servlet handler mapping
controller view resolver and view
these five components together help
render a web
mvc application in the spring framework
so that was about the theory of how
spring works
now let's move on to uh example to
understand how this works in action
so here i have already built a spring
mvc application
and if you're wondering how to build
that there's an easy way to do that
using spring initializer
and that's also the recommended way
actually if you go to the
documentation of spring you will see
that it recommends creating a new
project from
scratch using the spring initializer
utility which is provided by spring out
of the box
so just go to web a web browser and tar
and type
start dot spring dot io you will get
this page
where you can specify what type of
project you want to
create so it is going to create the
basic skeleton
for any spring application automatically
for you
it's probably like i said it's probably
the fastest way to get started with
spring
so we will choose a maven project maven
is again a dependency management tool
which is used to download any kind of
jars for your application
so we are going to use a maven project
and we want to
create a skeleton for a java application
we are going to use the latest
released version of spring or spring
boot which is 2.4.2
it says spring boot here but don't get
confused with it we are going to use
just the mvc classes and not the spring
boot specific logic
yet then you provide your group artifact
id
and the name for your jar you provide a
description
you can provide a welcome package name
whatever suits you
and then how you would like to run your
application whether you would like to
package your application as a jar file
which is a java archive or you would
like to run it as a web archive which is
a var file
so you can choose either packaging mode
and it is going to
add appropriate dependencies inside the
project
to support the packaging of jar or the
packaging of var
then you can also choose the java
version so you can see there are three
java versions listed here which are 8
11 and 15 so whichever java version you
are working on you can choose that
particular version
and once you have set all with
everything just hit generate
once you do that it is going to create a
project here and then you can import
this project
just as a normal project inside the
eclipse ide
and that's exactly what i've done for
this initial project which is
showing a very basic hello world sort of
example for how spring mvc will work
so this whole structure will
automatically be created for you and
like i said it was a maven project
and in every maven project you will have
a palm.xml
if i double click on this it is going to
open this xml and it will list down
all the dependencies which my project
needs to have
let's understand the dependencies as
well so this project is currently using
the properties of 1.8 but that's
and that's fine you can obviously
definitely change this value
i just kept it as 1.8 for now because
i'm not using any new functionality yet
in the dependencies section you will see
all the dependencies
or all the jars which are required by
the spring application
to run successfully the first dependency
we see here is
about daimy leaf and daimy leaf
basically
is a view technology similar to jsp or
similar to
servlets technically where you can
supply use this dye my leaf templates
which are basically just
htmls with some dynamic values and you
can use this dimei leaf templates to
render web pages
for your spring mvc application if you
want to use some other view technology
you need to include the dependency of
that view technology here
instead of dye my life so that's about
that then you need to
include the spring boot starter web the
spring boot starter web is going to
enable your application to become a web
application then
this is this is a this is basically a
good to have dependency which you can
have in your project
which will help you deploy the project
at runtime automatically without
restarting the server
because the web application will be
running on a
server on a web server basically or an
application server technically
because it needs to run somewhere so
that it so that clients can access it
that's how a web
client architecture work or the server
client architecture works
so this dependency will allow you to
deploy changes dynamically at runtime
without restarting the server then this
dependency is
for tests if you're writing any unit
tests
and then you have a plugin which will
allow to run this particular project
with a single
command which we will see in a while so
that's about the dependency tour
now let's look at what is in the src
main java
in the src main java i just have two
classes
one is the main class which will have a
public static void main method
and this is the entry point of this
spring application and
then i have a controller class i already
talked about what controller is but i
will come back to that in a while
let's understand the rest of the files
as well the next one is
src main resources where you will have
your view technology data available
like i mentioned it is using dye my leaf
templates currently
and basically like i said they are
technically htmls with some dynamic data
so i've created a templates folder under
src main resources which will
automatically be generated by spring
initializer
and then under templates i have placed
an html file
it's a pure html file with the only
difference is this value
so this is what the dynamic value means
which which is supported by dimer leaf
templates otherwise this is pure html
it's just a paragraph with a header and
this is the dynamic value which i'm
populating
it also has application.properties which
has nothing but you can use this
particular file to supply
environment specific properties for the
development environment or the testing
environment or the real production
environment
if you have any unit tests those will go
here under src test java
and this is the system library already
provided supported by eclipse itself
and i already talked about the palm.xml
you also see couple of more files
created by springboot
if you want to use that you can use that
to run the run the program from the
command line as a utility
otherwise you can just use ambient
spring boot command which i will show
you in a while
there's also a gradle folder which you
can ignore probably we don't need this
because we are just using
maven and we are not using gradle gradle
is another dependency management tool
very very similar to maven so you can
ignore this folder right now
so that's the structure and now let's
come back to the controllers
remember i told you that controllers are
the ones which receive the request so
from the dispatcher servlet which i
talked about here
after the dispatcher servlet the request
comes to the controller
so once you hit a particular url
then you need to create a controller for
that url mapping
remember that you need to create a
controller for almost every url mapping
you are having in your application
there should be some mapping to some
controller somewhere so i've created a
greeting controller
and the way you specify or you make a
simple class as a controller is by
putting the add the red controller
annotation this is the annotation which
is supported by spring
and you can put this annotation on top
of any class and that class will be
treated as controller
by spring and the moment the moment you
put this
this class will also be registered with
the dispatcher servlet
and like i mentioned the controller's
main purpose is to receive the requests
the web requests which are coming from
the client and the way
you can receive the requests to a
controller by providing the exact url
mapping so if somebody
runs this web application and says slash
greeting
then this particular method should get
invoked and how you define that is with
the get mapping annotation
use the get mapping annotation to
provide the url path whenever somebody
invokes this url path
this method would be getting called and
when this method is getting called
at that same time this url can also
accept some query parameters we call
that as the request parameters
in in the spring language so you can use
the request parameters
as an annotation to provide a
placeholder
for the variable for which the value
will be supplied in the url
so slash greeting if if you call this
url something like this
then it will work because you have a
variable called name which is
which is being parsed as a query string
because you have used the request
paramentation
so we'll see an example of that when
once we run this application and how we
can supply the query string but you use
the request param annotation to supply
the query string parameters to the url
you can mention if the parameter is
mandatory or non-mandatory
if the required equal to true was there
then this parameter would be mandatory
you can also supply a default value if
somebody is if
the client is not providing this query
parameter at all
would you like to set any default value
if yes you can supply that default value
here
and then you just give a placeholder
name like i said then the second
argument which
your your methods which are intercepting
the request
should have is the model argument and
remember i told you that the controller
will have
what should have the knowledge about the
model and from here
that knowledge comes you this particular
method will expect you to provide
a model argument as well so if somebody
calls this application and provides the
urls with slash
greeting this particular method will get
invoked and then
the code inside this method will be
getting executed
so it's a very simple code right now but
this is where your whole logic will go
remember that but here i'm just saying
model dot add
attribute name with the value which is
coming from the query string parameter
that's all i'm doing here and remember i
told you that the model will hold the
business logic
so here this is the business logic where
whatever query string parameter which is
coming from the
request param i'm capturing that and i'm
adding that value
with the variable name in the attributes
of the model so my model is set and
after that i need to return
the view so that this particular file
name
will be intercepted by the view resolver
here
if you remember we talked about the view
resolver so when we return
greetings as a string that string goes
here and then dispatcher servlet looks
out
asks the view resolver to find a
particular html
matching with this particular text so
view resolver is going to look at under
src main resources
slash templates to see if there is a
file with the name greeting available or
not
since we have that file available the
spring is going to
render this particular file supplying
the model attribute value name
now remember the greeting.html had the
exact
same variable name so this variable name
should exactly match with this variable
name here
if you do if you make a mistake here
this is not going to work because
the model is holding the business logic
and i'm printing that business logic
inside the view using the dye my lift
template syntax
which is dollar curly braces so whenever
you have to print any
variable or a model attribute or any
runtime value inside a dhammalife
template
then you need to use the dollar curly
braces
syntax to do that so that was about a
quick overview of how this application
is
is written right now and that's all the
code is here now it's time to run this
application
so one of the simplest way to run this
application would be to
provide a spring at the run
configuration here
for the spring application or you can
choose another way
which is to first have a look at the
spring web content application which is
the entry point
so once your application boots up this
is the first
line of code which is going to get
executed and to
make sure that this code works make sure
that you have the
add the red spring boot application
annotation on top of the
entry point class so this is this is
sort of the mandate which spring will
force you to put
in front of the or on top of the entry
point class
to to treat this class as the first
entry point when you run the project
so to run the project what we will do
that we will just go to the command line
and we will say
mvn spring boot run so let's do that and
let me open the terminal for that
so i have opened a get bash prompt here
you can also open the
classic windows terminal but this is
something which git
installs by default if you install git
on your system it's pretty much exactly
the same
it's just more unix-like but it's also
just a simple terminal shell utility to
access your file system
so i have gone to the project which we
were
working with in the eclipse ide and this
is the path of the project
so once you reach to the path what you
would like to run is
just say mvn spring hyphen
boot colon run that's it and you hit
enter once you write mvn sprinkle hyphen
boot call and run
you will see lot of code lot of logs
here where it is going to
run all the compile all the java classes
run any tests if
there are any and then it is going to
start
the web content application you can see
and once the application is started you
will get this message
that everything is run one of the
interesting thing which you can see here
is that it is also spinning up an
application server automatically for you
and that application server here which
is being used by spring
is apache tomcat technically apache
tomcat is a servlet container and it's
not a full-fledged
application server but just to get the
point across you can use
apache tomcat as an application server
which is being used here
out of the box by spring if you don't
want to use apache tomcat and you want
to use something else you can do that as
well
so now everything is ready and we can
now execute the application to
observe the output so for that let me
open a fresh browser window so that we
don't
get any cached response and now i can
just
type localhost 8080 and if i hit
entry enter i i get a white level error
page because there is no
home page for tomcat defined but there
is a home page for my application
defined
in fact let's try to access the url
which we wrote in the greeting
controller the url was
slash greeting so let's copy this and
let's put this here
so localhost8080 greeting
and if i hit enter i get the message
hello world let me just zoom this in a
bit so that you can see
so you will see this hello world message
here by putting this url
why do we see hello world let's go back
to the controller
so when you call this url this greeting
controller got invoked
since we did not provide any query
string parameter the default value which
was world
was picked up and this world value was
stored in the name variable
and the name variable was added as an
attribute to the model
and then we were using the greeting.html
and we were printing the name variable
since the name variable was holding the
value
world so the message came as hello world
with an exclamation and that's the
output which we see here
now let's try to supply the queries
query string parameter
the way you do that is provide a
question mark provide the
key of the query string parameter and
the value you want to put here
so let's put simply code as a value
and hit enter so now the message got
changed and now it says hello simply
code
so what happened here is that whatever
con
query string parameter we supplied that
got passed here at par
as part of the request param and the
value of simply code got stored in this
name key and in turn in this name
variable
and then i added the same value into
another name attribute
and added that attribute to the model so
now this name
here is storing the value simply code
and then the
all the things work exactly is the same
as i just described
it goes to greeting.html and it prints
whatever
is stored in the name attribute coming
from the model
let's get started with spring boot and
how we can build a simple
application using spring boot before we
go further let's understand why we need
spring boot
and the basic idea of spring boot is to
build restful web services if you want
to know more about what are restful
services please you can read about the
restful
concept as a concept what does rest
stand for but the basic
idea is that if you are accessing
anything
over http then that particular component
can be
built as a restful component and spring
boot is
the most popular choice for building
restful web services today
and even in fact microservices which you
might have heard about so you can build
microservices which also run on https
using spring boot
so what i'm showing you right now is the
official guide of spring which you can
use to build an application with spring
boot
it will list down all the requisites
which you need in terms of the
jdk installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc
you can again use the same springs
initializer which i talked about in the
previous session
you can use this to generate a spring
boot project for you
specifically so all those options are
available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just
did in the previous session and will
directly jump to an ide
where i have created a sample spring
boot application
and the structure here you can see the
structure would look very similar with
one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc
we had an src main resources folder and
that
src main resources folder was having all
the
web components or the htmls but since
in restful web services you do not
render
the html but you just send back the
response
the response can be the response body
can be
pure xml or it can be pure json but you
do not
send back and view and that's the main
difference between spring mvc and spring
boot
that in spring mvc it will you are
required to return a view technology
like in the in the previous session we
sent a dye my life template
which is basically in html you can also
written a gsp
but with spring boot you do not deal
with the view technology
and that's the world we are living in
today when you write spring boot
you do not have to worry about how this
is going to be rendered on the
web page whether it is going to be
rendered using html or whatnot
what you need to take care of using
spring boot
is to return the right response body
the exact text of the response and
that's it
so with that in mind the spring boot was
born and
the structure apart from that the
structure would look very similar
this palm.xml here which will provide
all the list of jars and dependencies
which are
required for this particular project so
you can see all the dependencies here
pretty much the similar ones we have a
starter web we have a starters test
and we have a spring boot maven plugin
and we have an application file
which is the entry point again having a
public static void main method
so you need to put the at the red spring
boot application
at the top of the class to make it an
entry point if you don't do this
spring boot will not run this class and
spring boot will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example
that we are just printing all the beans
which are provided by spring that's
all we are doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and the introductory session
so we will keep the logics to minimum
and i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
you get the bean definition
you get that with this application
context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application
is basically using this line where you
say string application
dot run and you supply application dot
class
with any command line arguments which
you might want to use
once you do this it is going to return
an application context
object to you and the application
context object
can be used to get all the bean
definitions by calling this method which
says get bean definition names
so that's the basic logic which is being
run in the main class
now we also have a controller but this
time it's not a web controller but it's
a rest controller
so you see in the previous example we
just had written something like this
it was just a pure controller but here
we have become more specific
we are saying that hey this is not a
simple mvc controller
but this is a spring boot controller or
technically a rest controller
so spring provides a separate annotation
for that which is at the rate rest
controller so you write that particular
annotation or that
on the top of the controller class which
you are creating and then you provide
a request mapping similar to what we did
in spring mvc
but while you return it you do not
return a view technology
you just return the raw response here
i'm just returning a string but you can
return a json object you can return an
xml object or whatever you want to
but not a view technology that's what
i'm doing like like you can see there's
literally nothing i'm doing in this it's
just a simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes
okay so that was all about what i have
written in the project and now it's time
to run the project
so i have just reached to the location
on inside my terminal where the project
bom.xml was present and if i just do an
ls you will see that there is a palm.xml
available
here and all the code directly is also
available here
so now i will just run this application
and to run this application i'm just
going to type mvn
spring hyphen boot colon run and hit
enter once i do that the spring
application is going to spring boot
application is going to get started
and let's go back to the controller and
actually the main app main end point and
see what we were doing there
i did a cis out here which said let's
inspect the beans provided by spring
boot
and then i was printing all the bean
names and if i go back to the output
i will see the same line being written
here which was around
let's inspect the beans so you can see
that message which says let's inspect
the beans provided by spring boot
and then all the beans which are
available in the
application context are printed here so
that's that's the basic idea
which i want to give you that you can
actually build a spring boot application
and you can write your rest controllers
return a string body from it
and once this is run then you can also
run your
application for from the web browser as
well
so let's try to hit that particular url
which i
wrote here so the url of hello so for
that let me just
open a new cognito window and our
application is already running so if i
just say http
localhost 8080 slash
i get this message here which says
greetings from spring boot
and this is the message which we were
sending from the rest controller
so this validates our understanding that
we can invoke a
rest controller which is a spring boot
rest controller
via the same method but this time we are
not getting an html but we are just
returning this particular string now you
can use the string in any ways
you want so it depends upon the consumer
so that's all i want to cover
as part of the spring boot now spring
boot is a huge huge topic
and we can spend hours and hours talking
about spring boot
but since this is more of an
introductory session so i just wanted
the concept to get introduced and
remember the value proposition of
why you would need spring boot the basic
idea is to build restful web services
or build restful micro services that's
the basic idea behind
using spring boot in your applications
and also remember the difference between
web mvc spring mvc application and
spring boot application
spring mvc is for building web
application spring boot is
for building restful applications which
might not have a web interface
integrated with them at that moment so
that's all i want to cover for this
particular session
and in the next session we are going to
have a look at an advanced java project
using some of the concepts which we
might have learned during this
whole journey and that would be the last
session of this particular tutorial
series
let's get started with our demo of a
project
which is using spring boot to build a
restful web service
so a restful web service is nothing but
any end point
which you can access or you can consume
the data from
via an http layer or via a simply a web
layer because most of the web traffic
which we deal with is
built on http so to take an example if
you go to any website
where you sometimes see on the top right
corner you see today's weather
so how is that today's weather coming in
it's coming in via a rest web service
the website which you are accessing is
basically hitting an http endpoint
which is where the where the weather
application is sitting
and it asks for the weather data and the
dressed web application just
returns the data and that's how the
website is able to show you the current
weather so restful web services are
everywhere
and they are the most popular way to
build applications today
where you just build your restful web
service and you expose an http url
and then the consumers need to just
access that http url to consume the data
from your application
and you see this makes it very easy
because there is no data type
restrictions there is no
tight coupling here it's just an http
endpoint
so that's the basic idea and we will
look at a project where we will be using
spring boot to build a restful web
service and then we will try to run that
web service
to save some data and also to return
some data so here on the
on the package explorer you see i have
created a project called rest service
and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it
so we have an src main java where i have
a package
and i have bunch of classes here and
before we go to the classes let's first
also
access the dependency file because every
project
needs some dependencies some jars to
execute it
for example spring itself is basically a
jar
so you need to include the spring jar in
your project so that your project can
become a spring project
and there are generally two dependency
tools one is maven
and one is gradle in this particular
project i am using maven
uh dependency tool for downloading and
managing the dependencies
which are needed to run this project
successfully and
the way you will find if it's a maven
project or if it's a gradle project
for a maven project you will see a file
called pom.xml pom.xml
and if it's a gradle project you will
see a dot griddle file that's how you
can spot
whether the project is using maven for
dependency management
or it is using gradle for dependency
management so let's open the palm.xml
since it's an xml file it will be a bit
verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand
first of all since this is a spring
project i need to include the parent
dependency which brings lot of
good defaults sensible defaults from
spring boot automatically and this is
the jar name this is the artifact id
which is
spring boot starter parent so any spring
boot project you are starting
do include this parent this parent is
basically bringing all the dependencies
from some other jar and you can make
your project as a as a child
of this particular parent so all the
spring board projects have this as a
parent
as a standard practice after that you
provide your own details in terms of
what is the
package name how do you want to see the
jar name on
what is the jar actual name what is the
jar version etc etc
you also set the minimum required java
version to run this application
and then you in the dependency sections
you provide all the jars which you need
to run your project successfully both
compile
and run your project successfully so we
added the spring boot starter web
on dependency which basically brings all
the dependencies
around making a controller or making a
repository
context component scan all the
interesting features which spring
provides
get wrapped up inside the spring boot
starter jar and you can actually go to
the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes
so i'm just telling you in a brief that
it provides all the restful
functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot
starter data jpa which is going to
enable this project to also have a
database
and if it has a database then you need
java
to talk to the database and the way
spring suggests to talk to the database
is why are using the spring boot data
jpa library we will see
this how this library can be used but
basically this provides
ways to represent your java object in
the database
and then you need to also add the actual
dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an in
memory h2 database
so i'm not using an external database
like mysql or oracle or pos
sql because that will just make more
configurations more complicated
i just wanted to keep it simple and
generally you in this h2 database you
can easily access by adding this
dependency
and it will be an in-memory database
created for you then i've also added a
spring boot starter test here
which will be used whenever you are
writing unit tests and you
must write unit test for your project
and then we need to add the plugin so
that springboot can run this project
that's all i have in the palm.xml now
let's move to the interesting part
the java section part let's start from
the main class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create
uh any any name with the class and then
you add a public static void main method
inside the public static void main
method you call
spring application dot run and
this run method is basically going to
run your application
and you just provide the same class name
which you just wrote here so just say
dot class
and if you're supplying any command line
arguments it can interpret that command
line arguments as well
if you want so you'd always need an
entry point
in an application and this is the entry
point which spring boot
supports and this is if you see this
code this is just normal code
to make spring be aware about this class
being treated as an entry point you need
to add add the red spring boot
application annotation on top of the
class
this is one of the annotation which is
coming directly from the spring boot
library you can see this import
so once you add this then only spring
will be able to treat this class as an
entry point
otherwise spring doesn't know where to
start from so when you run spring
it will fi it will try to find a class
with an annotation spring boot
application
and then inside the class it will try to
find a public start a static void main
method
and once it has found both of them then
it will just run the application
so it's very simple nothing fancy here
and what we are dealing with here is a
student object so we will try to insert
a student object
and we will try to retrieve the student
object so
if you ignore these annotations which
have added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object
you create a student class let's ignore
this field as well for now i'll just
come back to this annotation in this
field but this is just a student class
it has three fields as name age and
address an empty constructor
and a parameterized constructor and some
getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because
generally whenever you are building any
enterprise grade application
you would like to keep your objects
immutable
means once they have been created you
would not like somebody to allow
to change the values of the object this
just makes programming much much more
easy if you treat all the objects in
your application as
immutable that's why i have not added
setters here it's just considered a good
practice
so apart from the standard things which
we have already seen
there are two things here which i want
to talk about let's first talk about
this one
so accurate entity is the annotation
which is coming from java x
persistent entity persistence entity and
this
makes springboot save this particular
object into the database this is the
annotation which you need to put on your
class
so that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure
that this represents a table second
thing a table will have
a id it will have sort of a primary key
so i've created a new column called id
which is basically representing the
student's role number or something or
maybe a registration number
and here i'm using couple of more
annotations
if you see these annotations are also
coming from java x persistence library
and these annotations will basically
allow the
a new id to be created every time you
create a student object
so you don't have to specify the value
of this id variable
springboot will automatically generate a
new id value
every time you create a new student
object and how does it generate you you
can provide the generation type as well
so currently i've just said that set it
as automatic but you can set it as
identity
sequence or rate or controlled by table
you can also see the explanation of each
of these here but i've just kept it as
auto
which basically uh let the persistence
provider pick any appropriate strategy
for the particular database
in our case the database is h2 so that's
about the entity class let's call this
as entity class
now let's move to the repository so you
need
a repository class like i explained in
dots in that three tier architecture you
always need a dow layer or a repository
layer
to store your student object into the
database so we have enabled the student
object to be saved
but we need a handler which can save
this particular file
this particular object into the database
and the repository classes are the
classes which will allow you to do that
so you create a very simple interface
you what you name whatever you want to
name your interface as
and then you say extends jpa repository
the type of the object and the unique
identifier of the object so the type of
the object is student here
and the unique identifier of the student
object
is the id which is of type long so you
need to just supply the types
type of the object type of the primary
key or the type of the unique identifier
and this annotation is coming from
spring boot you can see
specifically spring boot data library
which we added so you just need to
create an interface
extend it from jp repository and make
sure that you add this annotation as
well
spring heavily uses the concept of
annotations and this will help
spring understand that this is a
repository layer class
and it will apply some more metadata to
this class while this class is running
in the jvm
so what happens here you just created an
interface you did not provide any method
to create or any method to delete or any
method to get
a student object because all of that is
automatically provided by springboard
via the jpi repository class
if we go inside this class and if you
scroll down you'll see the find all
method
find all find all by id save all flush
save and flush delete etc and if you go
further up
this also extends the paging and sorting
repository which provides pagination and
sorting
facilities but the interesting one is
that pagings and sorting repository
again extends a crud repository
and if you go to the crud repository you
will find all the basic methods to
save an entity save multiple entities
find an entity by the id that's why it
needed that long type
to make sure this that it can execute
this method you can check the existence
of an object
find all the entries find all by id
count them delete them
so all the basic crud functionality so
we call them as crud because
the reason it is called crud because
create read update
delete that's the basically the generic
acronym
so because uh this cred repository
provides all the
methods and their implementations
automatically we do not
need to write any code at all so that's
why spring boot is so awesome and that's
why springboard is very popular
because it's zero code in the repository
and you still get all the crud
functionality
so that's about repository now we have
covered the entity class we have covered
the repository class we have covered the
entry point class
now the only thing which is remaining is
the is the end point the http endpoint
which i talked about
and that you can create by creating any
class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class
and make sure that you put add the red
rest controller annotation on top of it
this annotation will allow spring to
treat this particular class as an
endpoint class
then you can auto wire the student
repository so if you remember i talked
about the whole dependency injection and
inversion of control so here dependency
injection is in action
so here you are just telling student
controller
to auto wire the student repository and
now what will happen
that at run time student controller or
actually spring
will automatically create an object of
the student repository
and supply that object of student
repository to student controller
so you as developer do not have to
create an
object of student repository explicitly
that's the benefit and that's how
the dependency injection is working
because you inverted
the dependencies now the dependency is
just injected
into the class and as a developer you
don't have to
take control of creating the objects
it's the spring which will automatically
read the autobot annotation and will
automatically supply an object whenever
it is required
then i have two methods here since we
are talking about http endpoints so
i have represented a post method here
and a get method here the way you will
write a post method is via at the rate
post mapping annotation
and then you can provide the url path on
which
somebody should call your endpoint to
save something
so for example somebody can call it http
localhost 8080
student slash create whenever they hit
that url the
control or that request will directly
hit this particular method
why because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation
so since it's a post method there would
be request body what is the actual
request body which the client is sending
and you can represent its uh request
body with the add direct request body
annotation
and you can provide the type of the
request body and here i'm saying that
hey if you want to access this
particular url
yes all good but you need to supply me
with a
text representation of the student
object or a json representation of the
student object
and then i inside the method i'm calling
student repository
dot save which is going to save the
student object which is coming in so you
see there's a lot going on here
i will i will show you how the student
is represented in the request body as
well and then i will come back to
how it got converted from json to java
but this is how you can store this
particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want
and keep inserting a new student object
every time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student
and then in the curly braces there's an
id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the
id of the student so generally there
would be another method here which would
be find all
to see all the students uh and with
their id
and then you can pick a particular
student's id supply that student id
value here dynamically that's why at the
curly braces curly braces supports
dynamic value
so here it can insert one two three or
whatever the student id
you want to fetch the value for you
provide that value in the student slash
id
and all good then some if somebody is
hitting the url with saying localhost
8080
slash student slash one then student
with the id one will be returned from
the request
and you need to put add direct get
mapping to make sure that this method is
treated as an http
get method and you can provide the type
you can
say get student and here this dynamic
value
is captured with the add the rate path
variable because you need to know the
id right whatever id somebody has
supplied in the url
you need to capture that ide and then
use that ide
for calling the repository so that's you
can do that by using the add variate
path variable
so here i'm just saying whatever id is
coming in i will store that value
inside this ide once i've done that then
i can again call student repository dot
find by id
which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the crud repository i
can supply the id
and this actually is going to return an
optional object
which is uh which is an object which may
or may not contain a value
so it said just a types of defensive
programming style
so this will return an optional and you
can call a get method to
return the actual student object this
will return an
optional of student so option of student
means that this optional object
may have a student or may not have a
student why did string
do that because the id somebody is
supplying
that id can be invalid also right so
optional object takes care of that that
if there is
no student found then you will not get a
null pointer exception
and if there's a student found you can
return that so it's just a defensive
programming style which spring has
adopted
by returning an optional of the student
object rather than directly the student
object
but if you're confident that this
particular option of student object
does contain a student object then just
call optional.get
which i've called here which will return
the actual student object
sitting inside the optional object you
can read more about the optional object
and its usage
uh from the official java docs and there
are tons of examples available on it
on internet so this is about the
controller uh we have covered all the
classes
now it's time to run the application so
you go to the command prompt you go to
the particular file folder location
and there you just say mvn
spring hyphen boot colon run so i just
hit
enter and this is going to run the
application
it's going to split some logs here and
if everything is fine you will not get
an
error and you will just be getting a
message saying that application got
started
and it's running on tomcat localhost
8080
with no context url so this is not a web
application this is a rest
full web service right this is a restful
service this is not a web application so
there is no web interface
so how do you access this you just have
an http url so you can use any of the
rest client available on the internet
there are probably hundreds of different
clients available on the internet you
can choose any one of them i am using
advanced rest client which you can also
install as an extension from the chrome
browser itself so
if you just if i just open the chrome
browser and i just say
rest client if you just write this and
hit enter
you will get many different options and
the first option you get is from
google play stores app store so you can
go to the app store that basically the
chrome web store not the
play store but the chrome web store and
you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so
this is pretty uh this is not a tutorial
for advanced rest client so i'll just be
quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say you want to do
a post
and then you can provide the url here so
remember the url which we
put here in the controller method this
has to exactly match
so http localhost slash student slash
create
should be the url so let me just copy
paste this one here
okay so the url is good here it's a post
type of method which i want to do and i
want to hit this particular url
now i need to supply the content type
and the body
so in the content type you can choose
application json because i'm going to
supply a json object
and in the body this is how the json
object looks like
advanced risk client also provides a
nice visual interface to
basically uh create this json if you are
thinking that json creation is very
tough it's not actually tough it's just
curly braces
and then you put key and value key value
comma
let me just put an enter here so that
it's more readable
so you just put curly braces starting an
end and then you just put key value
you put a key which is the variable name
and the variables value variable name
variable value and these keys have to
exactly match
the students properties so the
student.java had this name
age and address right so it has to
exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can
send this particular request when you
click send it is going to hit
my spring boot application which is
running on localhost 8080 it is going to
call the student slash create method
it is also going to convert this json
into a java object because here i am
supplying a java object
so it will convert the json which i'm
sending from here
to java object automatically and it is
going to automatically save it here
because i've called the repository.save
method so let's hit send here
once i hit send i get a 200 okay it
means everything went fine
and in the response header i get the
object back
because i have returned the object here
you see this save method is going to
return the same student object which you
created uh so everything is good here my
object has been
stored here and now it's time to fetch
the object
so it has already been saved into the h2
in memory database and you can
obviously go and connect to the
in-memory h2 database and have a look at
it
but for simplicity i'm just going to do
this here and
let's say the first object is generally
added as
the id 1 by default by the h2 database
so let's hit this particular url when i
hit this url it is going to hit
the student controller here and in the
student controller it is going to hit
the get student method
which is having a student id url
and it is going to find the database
with that id
and if it finds a student object with
that id
it is going to return that so let's
confirm that now
let's hit this particular send button
and it's going to hit a get request with
this particular url
springboard is going to find if a
student with the id 1
exists in its database so once i hit
send
i get a 200 okay and you see in the
response headers
i get the same student object back which
i added
let's try with 2 now let's see what
happens i see 2 and i get
500 internal server error because there
is no object stored
in the h2 database of the spring
application with the id 2
yet because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there
and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically
was one so when you hit for get request
with a student id one
you get the object when you put an
invalid value and you hit
this you get a 500 internal server error
you can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found
you can say something like that or else
throw
which is again an optional object and
here you can supply a particular type of
exception which you want to supply
instead of just throwing 500 internal
server error
but that's just additional thing
additional defensive programming you can
do
you can add more and more validations
and constraints into this project
as you build this project in a more
complex paradigm
so this is basically what i wanted to
show you that and
that we have created a spring up boot
application we have connected it to a
database
we haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller
we ran that application we used any
random rest client in my case i used
advanced stress client
and we first did a post request we
provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match
with the student objects property
especially the case of the names have to
exactly match
so if this all this matches then you
will get a response back that the object
has been created
if you want to fetch the value of the
object you're going to use the http get
method
and you again provide a url which has to
exactly match to some method
in some controller in the spring boot
application which is running on
localhost
and if you provide the right id you are
going to return get a valid result
if you provide an invalid id you are
going to get a 500 internal server error
and from here on you can make this
controller as robust and as mature as
you want you can add
find all method you can add update
student method
you can add a delete student method you
can have all different kinds of filters
like for example return to me
all the students starting with the name
a or return all the first
students with the role number one and
hundred are between one 100
so you can write as many endpoints as
you want and build this application
in as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want
and that's all i want to cover in this
particular lecture thank you and we'll
meet again in another session
thanks to our training experts it was
really a wonderful session
i hope this session was informative and
interesting if you have any queries
regarding the topics covered in this
particular tutorial
then please feel free to ask in the
comment section below our support team
will be happy to help you out with all
your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here